ما في أحد يولد مثلي الجنس؟
لا، أبدًا. أنا لما أشوف مثلًا بالعيادة يجوني مراهقين
يحكي عن عمليات تغيير الجنس
وبيحكي بكل بساطة ومعلومات طبية
وكلها تكون غلط، من فين جايبها؟
يجي الأب جنبه مسكين فاتح فمه
ومو فاهم ولا كلمة من اللي بيقولها ولده
أنا حالات مرت عليّ لشباب وبنات هنا
لما عارضوا لأهاليهم هذا التوجه ورفضوهم أهاليهم
من باب أن ألوِّ ذراعه أو أبتزّه عاطفيًّا، تعرف أيش صار؟
فيه مواقع كثير تقول لهم بس صوّر لنا صورة جواز سفرك
تجيك تذكرتك على طول، عائلة تتبناك هناك
ندخلك في نظام التعليم، وكل شيء مجانًا لك؛ وراحوا
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية
وأنا عبدالرحمن أبو مالح
أول شيء، طز بأمريكا والقيم الغربية
لدينا قيم مجتمعية عظيمة، يجب أننا نركز عليها ونعظّمها
منها التكاثف الأسري والمجتمعي
اللي بيجي في كثير من هذه الحلقة
اللي أشوفها مهمة لكل أب أو أم
أو لكل أحد مقبل على مرحلة الوالدية
62% من الأزواج الأمريكيين يقولون
أن الوالدية أصعب من ما توقعوا
دراسة ثانية تقول أن 45% من الوالدين
ما يعرفون يروحون لمن إذا احتاجوا المعونة
بخصوص التربية والعناية بالطفل
وهذا طبيعي في مجتمع فرداني
طيب، ماذا عن مجتمعنا العربي؟ مجتمعنا السعودي؟
كيف الشكل الصحي للانتقال من مرحلة الزوجية إلى الوالدية؟
كيف نقدم الرعاية والتواصل والتواجد للطفل في مراحله المتعددة؟
من فترة الحمل حتى سنتين مثلًا
وخصوصًا في هذه المرحلة العمرية
إذا كان دور الأم واضح، فما هو دور الأب؟
ويكبر الطفل، تزداد تعقيداته ومتطلباته
المنظمات الصحية العالمية كلها وكل الدراسات
تحذّر من الأجهزة في أيدي الأطفال، حتى سن متأخرة
رغم ذلك، كل الأطفال أو معظمهم تشغل أياديهم الجوالات
في هذه الحلقة، راح نتكلم عن المخاطر هذه من ناحية علمية
كيف نتعامل مع الطفل في هذه المرحلة، وفي مرحلة المراهقة؟
وكيف تواجه التحديات اللي تكون في أبسط أشكالها مثل العناد؟
وأصعب أشكالها مثل ميول طفلك الجنسية؟
الحلقة مع الدكتورة «هبه حريري»
معالجة نفسية، وعضو في هيئة تدريس جامعة جدة
قبل أن نبدأ
عملنا الفترة الماضية على فلم وثائقي مختلف
عن شخصية فنية من الطراز الرفيع
وصفها «طلال مداح» بأنه منافسه في الساحة الخليجية
تعرّض لمواقف سياسية شائكة
وأحداث غيّرت مسار حياته وتسببت في اعتزاله لفترة
هذا الفنان هو «خالد الشيخ»
والفلم بعنوان «خالد الشيخ بين أشواك الفن والسياسة»
يحكي فيه «خالد» قصته بلسانه
ويجيب على أسئلة كثيرة حول مسيرة الفنية ومواقفه السياسية
في سرد وثائقي بديع من إخراج «جمال كتبي»
أنا وفريق ثمانية بانتظاركم في العرض العالمي الأول للفلم
في مهرجان البحر الأحمر السينمائي بتاريخ 2 ديسمبر
والمقاعد محدودة
لذا تركت لكم رابط الحجز في وصف هذه الحلقة
شكرًا لراعي الحلقة شركة «صفا» ومنصة «سلة»
أما الآن؛ لنبدأ
في أحد من الأصدقاء، هو زميل برضه في الشركة
ما يحبك أبدًا
واو! لطيف، بس ليه؟ أيش سويت له؟
هو أيش يقول؟
الله يحفظ له أولاده، عنده بنت وولد
بنته الظاهر الآن سبع أو ثمان سنوات، وولده أصغر
المهم، في حلقتك السابقة، هو ما أعجبته أبدًا
هو يقول كفاية حركات غربية، أنا ما أحب الحركات هذه
أبويا كان يجلدني وأنا تعلمت ومشيت
وهم بينجلدوا، وحياتنا مثل ماهي
أنا ما أحب التربية الغربية
فزعلان، ما يحب. يحس أنك تعطين التربية أكبر من حجمها
عشان ضغطت له على جرح شكلي
لا، بس أن فيه كثير يقولون سالفة اليوم
التربية وما أدري أيش ولازم أنا...
الحين فيه برضه بعضهم اللي يقول لك لازم تاخذ دورة
عشان كيف تربي أولادك
ليش هذا كله؟
كل الناس على مرة السنين، مو لازم نتكلم حتى مئة سنة، لا، من يومها
الناس تجيب أولاد وتتربّى، وفيه ناس تربيتهم جيدة
وما كان يتطلب هذا الجهد
حتى كانوا زمان يتزوجوا وهم أصغر بكثير من الحين
الحين هو يتزوج عمره ثلاثين؛ لا، وأهّله أنه يصير أب، سلامات!
ما تحسي أنه بالغنا في سالفة التربية؟
ما أشعر أن احنا بالغنا، لأن احنا لو جينا زمان
مصادر التعلم مقارنة بمصادر التعلم الآن؛ اختلفت
طبيعة المجتمع الزمان مش مثل طبيعة المجتمع الآن
التحديات الوالدية اللي كانت على زمن جدي وجد جدي
مش مثل التحديات الوالدية اليوم
أعطيك مثال من مقابل آخر
جدي مثلًا لما تعلم صنعته ما راح إلى جامعة
ولا أخذ رخصة ولا أخذ دورات ولا شيء، صح وللا لا؟
صحيح
ونجح ومشي وأسس حياته
وبنوا البلد بهذيك الإمكانيات والتحديات
اليوم أقدر أنا آخذ نفس مسار جدي
ما أدخل جامعة ولا دورات ولا شيء؟
بضيع. بحس أن الظروف والوضع يتطلب
أن أنا لازم آخذ بعين الاعتبار أيش التغيّرات اللي صارت
وكيف أشعر بالتمكين فيها كإنسان
كذلك نفس الشيء على التربية
زمان مثلًا كانت (takes a village to raise a child)
وحرفيًّا كانت القرية كلها وللا الحارة
وللا الأسرة الممتدة؛ تساعد وتساهم
اليوم ما عندنا هذا الامتياز
أنا كأم مثلًا، أشعر أن أنا في مدينة إسمنتية منعزلة
لربما في مكان ثاني
فبالتالي أحتاج مصادر تختلف عن مصادر جدتي
وعن مصادر أجدادنا اللي راحت
فهي مسألة أيش التغيير اللي بيصير
وكيف أقدر أنا أكون متمكّنة أو مواكبة أو متناغمة ومتوافقة
مع هذه التغييرات اللي بتصير
ماهي مسألة شيء استوردناه من برّا
ويلا نسخ لصق نبغى نسوّيه عشان نشعر بالحداثة
هي ماهي كذا، هي تتاخذ ببُعد أوسع شويه
احنا سجّلنا وللا إيش؟
سجّلنا
بدأتوا؟ طيب قول كان رتبت الإجابة أكثر
لا، إجابتك مرتبة دائمًا
هل أغلب الناس جاهزين أنهم يكونون أب وأم؟
صراحة لا
والله؟
أيوة. خلينا نعطيها إجابة واسعة
دائمًا نقول الحب فطرة
الشعور هذا الأبوي وللا الأمومة، هذا شيء نتولد فيه
وتشوفه في الأطفال لما يلعبوا بالعرايس
ويتخيلوا أنهم ينيموهم ويشربوهم
هذا يعكس لك فطرة الإنسان أن هو مولود ومستعد
لهذه المشاعر الطيبة، للرعاية، للاحتواء، للحماية
هذه كلها أشياء نولد فيها، وهذه من رحمة وحكمة الله
فهذا شيء
لكن لما نجي نقول التربية والتنشئة
وكيف أبني هذا البناء النفسي والاجتماعي والعقدي والروحي
في هذا الإنسان، اللي الله استودعه عندي
هذه تحتاج إلى تعلم، كيف التعلم؟
مو بالضرورة يكون بالشكل الجديد إذا بتقوله
أنه أقرأ كتابه أو أحضر دورة
ممكن محادثة مع أشخاص سبقوني في هذا المجال مثلًا
ممكن من الأسرة الممتدة، من والدي، من تجاربي أنا
فهي المصادر تتغير، بس هل كلنا جاهزين
أن احنا نعمل عملية التربية والتنشئة؟
لا. هذه تحتاج، أنا دائمًا أقول الوالدية
هذه اللي أسميها الوالدية، التربية
هي عملية من النمو والتعلم اللا منتهية
أنا ما انتهي يفترض
ما أقدر أقول أنا تمكّنت من كل شيء كأم
ويلا جاهزة أبدأ الآن، ببدأ أخلّف
هي ما تجي بهذه الطريقة
هي احنا نستمر في التعلم معاهم
وترى كل طفل يجيك ويجي يعلمك
ودائمًا تسمعها بالعامي نقول هذا الولد رباني، هذه البنت ربتني
ما نقصده أن يجوا أبناءنا ويخلقوا علينا تحديات جديدة
سواءً على صعيدنا الشخصي وللا الاجتماعي، الفكري
ممكن حتى الروحي والديني
وبالتالي هذه فرص لنا للتعلم وللنمو مع أبناءنا
هي عشان لا نجيبها بطريقة كأننا مكائن
أنا مو لازم أحضر دورة وآخذ شهادة؛ ويلا بحمل
هي ما تجي بهذه الطريقة
ولكن فيه احنا نسميها الحد الأدنى
اللي هو أيش الأساسيات اللي أحتاج أكون واعية عنها
أكون منتبهة عنها، أجمعها في جعبتي قبل ما أدخل هذه الرحلة
وأحط في بالي أن خلال هذه الرحلة لآخر يوم في عمري
أنا دائمًا بستزيد، دائمًا بنمو
دائمًا عندي فرصة للمحاولة والخطأ، للنمو وللنضج
أيش الأساسيات طيب؟
أول أساس، وهذا اللي كثير يغفلوا عنه
عشان مو للأطفال، عننا احنا نفسنا
دائمًا نقول أن أخطر شيء
وهذا اللي أنا اللي دائمًا أشوفه في الاستشارات والعيادة
يجوا ويشتكوا من الطفل، والطفل ما فيه إلا العافية
أولادهم ما فيهم إلا العافية، تمام، سليمين
طيب فين المشكلة؟ المشكلة بداخلنا
ففيه مقولة دائمًا نقولها
الوالدية تبدأ من الداخل، وبعدين من الخارج
بمعنى لو جبتها بالعامي، أنا لو عندي كلاكيع من جوّا
أنا لو شعوري أني مو جيد بما يكفي
أنا ماني واثق من نفسي ومن إمكانياتي
أنا مرتبك، أنا ما أحد يحبني، أنا غير مقبول
لا تعتقد أن هذه الكلاكيع الصغيرة ما بتظهر على أبناءك
بالعكس هي أول ما بتسقط؛ بتسقط على أبناءك
لأن هذول هم البشر اللي تشعر في دائرتك القريبة جدًّا
وللا بيختبروك كثير في مواقف عاطفية
فلو أنا مثلًا أشعر أني ماني جيد بما يكفي
فبالتالي لما يكون طفل ويبكي طول الليل ومو عارف ينام
أيش بيسوي؟ بيضغط لي على هذا الملف المقربع اللي بداخلي
أن أنا مو جيد بما يكفي
بهلع كأم، ليه بيبكي؟ أنا ماني عارفة له
هو طول الليل متعبني، ويبدأ يجيني شعور أن أنا أم مو كويسة
وأتوتر وأتصل على فلان، وأفضل بس أشتكي
فضاعت متعة الأمومة، ضاع الحضور العاطفي
اللي يحتاجه طفلي في هذه اللحظة، ليش؟
لأن بكاه ضغط على هذا الشيء الداخلي
اللي هو خلينا نسميها الشعور بذاتي
واحنا نسميها unfolded issues، المشكلات
أو خلينا نقول، ما أبغى أسميها عُقد
بس لما نسميها أشياء غير محلولة في داخلنا
فبالتالي أول خطوة في الوالدية
هي أعرف نفسك من الداخل، تواصل مع نفسك
لأن لو أنا تواصلت مع نفسي، تواصل صحي وجيد
بيكون عندي المقدرة على الحضور الكامل مع أبنائي
الحضور العاطفي، الحضور الذهني، الحضور الاجتماعي
فبالتالي هذا الحضور بيساعدني أني أساعدهم هم كمان
يكونوا متواصلين مع أنفسهم
أسوأ شيء يا عبدالرحمن، أن احنا نمشي بذي الحياة ما نعرف نفسنا
وبالتالي لما تصير لنا تحديات ومشاكل
نغرق في شبه الموية، ليه؟
لأني ما أعرف أنا من فين
ليش فجأة عصبت؟ ليش هذا الموقف أربكني؟
ليه هذا الوظيفة أخاف منها؟
ليه هذا الاجتماع لما أدخل أحس أن كلامي (غبي) ما أحد بيسمعه؟
ليه هذا كله؟
بعدين كيف نتفاعل معاه؟
نقوم نتفاعل معه بالانسحاب أو بالعنف الزائد
أو بالاستعراض الزائد أو بالمثالية والكمال أسعى له
أو أصير ممتعة، بس أبغى أسعدكم
تعرف ذول اللي يرموا نفسهم بالحلال والحرام في الشغل؟
بس المهم ارضوا عني، لأن أنا عندي خوف وارتباك من داخلي
فبالتالي هذا التواصل مع أنفسنا يخدمنا أولًا احنا كأفراد
ويخدمنا في والديتنا مع أبناءنا
فهذا أعظم شيء ممكن نقدمه لأبناءنا
هو تواصلنا احنا الصادق الشفاف مع أنفسنا
بالتالي هذا يبدأ يكون عندنا عافية نفسية جيدة
أبناءنا ما يبغونا أغنياء، ما يبغونا مهرجين
ما يبغونا عبارة عن تلبية رغبات
يبغوك حاضر، متواصل، قريب
هذا اللي يحتاجه الإنسان لأجل ينمو، نمو آمن وسليم
كيف أنا أتواصل مع داخلي؟
أيش الشكل المثالي عشان أجهز نفسي؟
أبشط شيء أعطِّ وقت لنفسك
أنا دائمًا أدخل على الإعدادات في الجوال
وأروح على وقت الشاشة مثلًا
وشوف كم قمت جلست على التيك توك وإنستقرام
أنا نفسي يكون فيه خدمة قد إيه قعدت مع نفسك
منقطع عن كل العالم الخارجي
وأنت جالس مع عالمك الداخلي
مع الخبرات اللي تمر عليها في اليوم
حقيقةً ممكن ما تتجاوز ولا دقائق، وفيه ناس ولا ثانية حتى
حياته كلها في العالم الخارجي
طيب بداخلنا عالم داخلي كبير
مشاعرنا، أفكارنا، قناعاتنا، حتى قيمنا الروحية
خبراتنا اللي مرّينا فيها
فيه مواقف تمر ما خططنا لها وتقربعنا من جوّا، تأثر علينا
قد إيه جلسنا وعملنا إنعكاس، استبصرنا فيها
عرفنا أن هذا الموقف لما زعلت فيه بزيادة
مو عشان هذا الموقف، لا هو أقدم من ذلك
ذكرني بذكرى قديمة، شكلي كنستها تحت السجاد وقلت خلّصت
لا، بس هي طلعت على السطح مع هذا الموقف
فالوقت، احنا بحاجة إلى وقت مع أنفسنا
وما هو شيء مُعقد
نشعر أنه معقّد في اليوم اللي احنا نعيشه دحين
لأن اليوم صار سريع، مسؤوليات كثير
عندنا سعي عالي جدًّا أننا لازم ننجز أشياء كثيرة وسريعة
منافسة في العمل وغيرها
فضاعت أوقاتنا مع نفسنا
فأول خطوة هو أوجد وقت لنفسك، هذا شيء أول
الشيء الثاني، البداية بتكون صعبة
دائمًا احنا مثلًا بالعيادة لما نقول تواصل، أبحث
مثلًا، يقول أنا متضايق
متضايق هذا ماهو شعور
أنت شيل هذه الطبقة، أيش تحتها؟ غضبان
شيل هذه الطبقة، فيه تحت الغضب
دائمًا الغضب أقول له مثل اللحاف يغطي شيء
إحباط، طيب إحباط من مين؟ من الناس
طيب شيل هذا الإحباط، تحته فيه شعور، عجز
أشعر بالعجز مثلًا أو أشعر بالعار أو أشعر بالفشلة
شيل هذا الشعور، أيش تحته، وهكذا
احنا بحاجة أن نتعمق في مشاعرنا ونفهمها
وأفهم كمان متى هذه المشاعر تربكنا، في أيش المواقف
ممكن مثلًا تجي بنتي تبكي من المدرسة، تنمروا عليها
المطلوب أن أنا أكون حاضرة عاطفيًّا معاها
بس كثير من الأمهات، مين آذاكِ؟ من سوّى كذا؟
برفع سماعة للمدرسة، لأبهدله؟
فياخذ ردة فعل ممكن على المدرسة
يصب جام غضبه، ليش؟
لأن هذا الموقف أشعره أن ممكن...
مرة ثانية نجي لهذه الطبقات
مثلًا أنا عاجز، أنا محبط
أو ممكن يكون عندي أنا ألم قديم مثلًا
أنا ما أحد كان يدافع عني
فالآن أنا بنفّذ أجندتي القديمة على بنتي
أنا بطلع أدافع عنها
أو العكس، أنا ممكن أصب جام غضبي على بنتي
أنتِ اللي أحوجتِ نفسك، أنتِ اللي مزودتها، أنتِ اللي مدلعة
فما يكون الموقف متزن
طيب ليش ماهو متزن؟ نحتاج نتأمل
هذا معناته أن أنا لما حطيت غضبي على بنتي
يمكن ذكرتني في نفسي مثلًا
في هذا الألم اللي أنا عشته مثلًا أنا طفلة صغيرة
أنا كانوا يتنمروا عليّ وما كنت أعرف أيش أسوي
فكنت أتمنى أكون قوية
فالآن هذه الأمنية القديمة، الأجندة القديمة
أجي أسقطها بسرعة على هذا الطفل
قوِّ نفسك، تصرف
ونصير بزيادة حاطين جهد عاطفي في هذا الموقف
ماهو بقدر هذا الموقف
لأن أنا شلت قدر زمان وحطيته عليه
تصير مواقف مجهدة علينا وعلى أطفالنا
فالتواصل مع أنفسنا، الشفافية مع أنفسنا
تخلينا أولًا نرتب البيت الداخلي فينا
فبالتالي أقدر أفصل ما بين آلامي أنا ومخاوفي أنا
وما بين هذا الوقت الحاضر الصغير البسيط مع أبنائي
كلامك رائع، بس أنه صعب،صعب من أكثر من ناحية
بس سالفة التواصل الداخلي، وأن أنت بس تكلم نفسك؛ هذا لحاله صعب
الساعة أحيانًا ترسل لي خذ دقيقة واحدة
بس تنفس وخلك مع نفسك شوي
دقيقة واحدة، وما عمري سويتها
إلا يمكن مرة واحدة أول ما اشتريت الساعة
يمكن هذا قبل ثلاث أو أربع سنين
فأنك تاخذ دقيقة واحدة عشان تخرج من العالم الخارجي
وترجع إلى ذاتك؛ صعب
إذا أخذنا أنه يتطلب أحيانًا
بس تواصلك الداخلي مع نفسك، يمكن ما يعطي حل
يمكن ما أعرف كيف أتواصل مع نفسي
لأن لها أدوات أتوقع
إذا تواصلت أنا شلون أعرف أن عندي الكلاكيع هذه؟
كيف أجلس إلى أن أعرفها؟ كيف أحلها؟
كيف أعرف أني حليتها؟
يبدو لي أنه يقودني إلى أن أروح لمعالج نفسي أو طبيب نفسي
بعدين ندخل في طبيب نفسي
هل هو رفاهية وللا لا؟
إذا مو برفاهية، فهل أصلًا معناته أني بس أصرف فلوس لأنهم غاليين
وأنتم غاليين
فالجلسات 300 ريال، 400 ريال، 500 ريال على الجلسة الواحدة
ويادوب بسم الله نفتح الباب
فتشوفي أنه مرة صعب الموضوع
ومو بهذه البساطة مثل ما قلتيها أنتِ
فلما أجي فعلًا أفكر، كيف أقدر أعكسها على حياتي؟
صعبة جدًّا
أتفق معاك. هي صعبة، لأن ماهي ثقافة تربينا عليها أو كبرنا عليها
أضف إلى ذلك سرعة الحياة كل ما لها بتزيد
أعباء الحياة كل ما لها بتزيد
المشتتات كل ما لها بتزيد
أنا عشت في زمن مثلًا من بعد العشاء التلفون ما يرن بالبيت
إلا إذا في حالة وفاة، لا قدر الله
فأنت متخيل مثلًا أمي كأم، لو جينا أخذنا مثال جيل أمهاتنا
كانوا خلاص ينفصلوا عن العالم الخارجي بكل سهولة
لأن ما في شيء يقتحم حياتهم
فهم من بعد العشاء الين الصباح؛ هم في عالمهم الداخلي
اليوم ما نقدر
اليوم أنت حروب العالم كلها لأخر اللحظة قبل ما تنام، تجلس تتابعها
إذن معناته فعلًا فيه عبء علينا اليوم، وهذا لازم نعترف فيه
أنا ما أبغى أنظّر وأكون مرة مثالية
افصل نفسك من برّا واجلس مع نفسك
نعم هي فيها تحدي، مو أن ما فيها تحدي
هل مستحيل؟ لا. هل ممكن؟ نعم
لكن تحتاج إلى أنه أحط هذا الجهد
خليني أعطيك مثال
الرياضة مثلًا، إلى الخمسة سنين اللي راحت
أعداد النوادي مثلًا تمشي في المجمعات السكنية
نادرًا ما تلاقي نوادي رياضية
اليوم في كل بلوك ممكن تلاقي نادي رياضي
ليش اليوم الناس صار عندها وقت للرياضة؟
هم نفسهم الناس قبل خمس سنين، ليش؟
صار عندهم وعي يمكن؟
بالضبط. وعي، صارت أولوية
صرنا مستوعبين أن الصحة الجسدية تعكس على صحتك النفسية
صارت نوعًا ثقافة اجتماعية عُمّمت؛ طبّعنا معاها، آمننا فيها
فبالتالي قامت مؤسسات كثير تساعد على هذا الموضوع
تساعد فيه رواد أعمال، صاروا يستثمروا فيها
فهي نفس الشيء اليوم
وعلى فكرة مسألة هذا التواصل
خليني أعطيك دراسة قديمة صارت
صارت على 2000 سيدة (تعساء في حياتهم الزوجية)
لما جاوا شافوا مين تعاستها الزوجية
تؤثر على صحتهم وعلى أشكالهم، بشكلها الخارجي
بسبب هذا التعاسة
وجدوا أن فيه مجموعة يبان شكلهم أكبر من سنهم
ويشتكوا من آلام جسدية مزمنة
ومرتبطة بهذه التعاسة في حياتهم الزوجية
في المقابل هناك سيدات شكلهم ما بان أكبر من عمرهم
ما عندهم آلام جسدية وهما أيضًا تعساء في حياتهم الزوجية
أيش الفرق بين هنا وهنا؟
هذول يجلسوا يتحلطموا مع بعضهم بالعامي
هذول السيدات عندهم مجتمعات نسائية
يفضفضوا لبعض، يحكوا مع بعض، يتكلموا مع بعض
وهذا يذكرني دائمًا بحديث السيدة عائشة، وهو أطول حديث تكلمته
لما حكت مع الرسول عليه الصلاة والسلام
عن كيف كل واحدة صارت تشتكي عن زوجها
وهذيك الصحابية اللي بعد سنين من العشرة تزوج عليها زوجها
فقال لها الرسول كنت لكِ...
ناسيه نص الحديث، بس كيف الحديث يشرح لنا
لو جينا شفناه كذا بتصغير
جلسة نسائية فيها تعبير عن ما يجوب في داخلهم من مخاوف
من مشاعر من أفكار
هذا اللي بنقول عليه صعب اليوم؛ هو بيحدث من قديم الزمان
بس احنا ما صرنا نعطي له مساحة في حياتنا
فإذن احنا بحاجة أن نرجع نستعيده مرة ثانية
فلما تقول التواصل يحتاج لعيادة نفسية
مو بالضرورة يحتاج لعيادة نفسية
احنا نحتاج نعرف أن يوم أطلع وأحكي مع إنسان قريب مني صديقة أو أخت
ولما أفضفض ولما أتواصل مع مشاير
ربما هذه كلها وسائل مجانية تساعد
تساعد أن الإنسان يسهل عليه التواصل
طيب بالنسبة أنتِ ذكرتي الوالدية
هل فيه فرق بين الوالدية والزوجية؟ أزواج أو والدين؟
أيوة
أيش الفرق بينهم؟ هل كل زوجين قادرين أن يكونوا والدين؟
مرة ثانية، العلاقة الزوجية هي علاقة بين اثنين بالغين
العلاقة الوالدية هي تأخذ شكل آخر
تاخذ علاقة الشراكة مع هذه الأسرة والأبناء ونموها من كل الأصعدة
احنا دائمًا نظن أن التربية هي أن أنا...
أولًا دائمًا نقول الشكل المعمم عند كل الناس
أكّله وشرّبه ودخّله مدرسة كويسة
هذا اللي احنا نسميه الحاجات الفيسيولوجية
هذه الطبقة الأولى في الاحتياجات الإنسانية
بعدها يجي شوية أهل عندهم وعي أكثر
أنه أبغى اهتم في أفكاره، كيف يفكر، كيف يحلل وغيره
هذه التربية فكرية مثلًا ممكن تكون
بعض الناس تهتم بالتربية العاطفية
وهي هذه كيف يعبر عن مشاعره، كيف يتواصل
كيف يدير غضبه، إحباطه وغيره
فيه ناس عندها تربية مثلًا روحية
بس التربية أشكالها مرة كثير، هي مو بس هذه الطبقات
أيضًا التربية الروحية تأخذ دور، التربية الاقتصادية تلعب دور كبير
وفيه أهل كثير يحسبوا أن هذا الطفل أيش فهّمه
بس من عمر مبكر، لا بد أن فلسفة المال، استخدامه، الادخار
هذه تدخل فيها التربية
أنا بجي لتربية للأطفال، بس أنا ودي الآن على الطرفين
هل لازم الطرفين كلهم يكونوا جاهزين؟
وللا طرف واحد كافي أن يكون
مثلًا الأم هي الأهم، وهي اللي كافية أنها تكون جاهزة
طيب أنا أعطيك إجابة مثالية وإجابة واقعية
الإجابة المثالية نعم، يفترض الطرفين
لأنه مجهد جدًّا أن طرف واحد هو اللي يحمل العبء بالكامل
الصورة الصحية، بلاش أقول المثالية حتى
الصورة الصحية أن الاثنين يحملوا العبء
أكيد بتكون فيه فروقات بينهم
أكيد يمكن واحد متمكن في الجانب العاطفي
واحد في الجانب الاقتصادي وغيره، واحنا نكمّل بعض
وهذه في الأخير سنة الله بين البشر
أن احنا نكمل بعضنا، لأن ما في أحد كامل
ولكن جرت العادة وحتى، سبحان الله، فيما يخص الوالدية
أن الأمومة هي اللي تلعب الدور الأكبر، الرضاعة وغيرها
الأم نعم يقع عليها الدور الأثقل يمكن في أوائل السنوات
هذا لا يعني أن يعطي إذن للأب أن أنت ما لك دور الآن
بس طبعًا الأم يقع عليها دور كبير
هل صحي إذا شاف أحد الطرفين أو أحد الزوجين
أن الطرف الآخر غير جاهز لأن يكون أب أو أم، أن يؤخر الإنجاب؟
كلمة غير جاهز كمان هذه كلمة مرة واسعة
وناخذها على طرف
عمره الإنسان ما راح يكون جاهز 100%
وممكن الآن أنا أكون أم، وأشعر أن فيه عندي أجزاء من الحياة
أنا غير جاهزة فيها
لو أعطيك إياها مثلًا على صعيد العواطف
أنا يمكن جاهزة في التعامل مع الغضب
بس ماني جاهزة في التعامل مع شعور الفقد يمكن
فالجاهزية كلمة مرة واسعة ولها طيف كبير
فخلينا نقول جاهزين 100%؟ ما في أحد بيكون جاهز 100%
بيجي طفلك مولود أصلًا بـ 60% من صفاته موروثة
يفاجئك بأشياء كثير ما تتخيلها. فالجاهزية تختلف
فهل نكون جاهزين 100%؟ ما في أحد يكون جاهز
عشان كذا كثير الناس يقول مو جاهز
عمرك ما راح تكون جاهز 100%
لكن حط في بالك أن أنا إنسان قابل للتعلم
للنمو، للنضج دائمًا مع أبنائي
متى ما يكون جاهز تمامًا؟
لما يشعر أن أنا ما عندي إمكانية لتحمل المسؤولية
وبرضه المسؤولية كلمة واسعة
لما مثلًا أم تجي وتقول أنا ماني مستعدة أصحى في الليل كل شوية أرضّع
أنا ماني مستعدة أترك عملي
وعملي يتطلب عدد ساعات عمل طويلة
ماني مستعدة للأشياء الأساسية
وفيه وضوح أن أنا تمامًا مو مستعد
حقيقةً هنا نقول إذن أيوة
لا تجيبوا إنسان على هذا الدنيا وينحط بين يد خدم
بس عشان كملنا الصورة قدام المجتمع، أب وأم وطفل
بس في الحقيقة هذا الطفل مهمل يكون
أو أبوه وأمه غير قادرين على رعايته
ورامين رعايته على أطراف كثير جدّة وعاملة
هذا يؤلمنا كثير، وثمنه ماهو سهل لا على الطفل
لا في الوقت القريب ولا حتى في الوقت البعيد
أيش الحد الأدنى بين الطرفين اللي يقولون احنا جاهزين الآن؟
جاهز أنك تتحمل هذه المسؤولية
جاهز أن أنت تكتشف نفسك
مع هذا الإنسان الصغير اللي بيجي بين يدك
جاهز أن يكون عندك استعداد لكل أشكال الرعاية
رعاية جسدية، رعاية عاطفية
خليني أقول الحد الأدنى، وهنا عشان كمان للعدالة
أنا ممكن يكون الحد الأدنى عندي مقارنة بشخص آخر هذا الحد الأعلى عنده
فالناس تختلف
عشان كذا نرجع مرة ثانية، أعرف نفسك
التواصل مع النفس هو اللي بيجاوب على هذه الإجابة
هل ممكن أعرف نفسي من خلال الطرف الآخر؟
فهل ممكن يساعدون بعض في اكتشاف أنفسهم؟
طبعًا، لأن، سبحان الله، الأسرة أصلًا تمر بمراحل
المرحلة الأولى دائمًا فيها تحدي مرة كبير
لأن الطرفين يجوا ينجمعوا في ساحة وحدة
وكل واحد جاي من ساحة مختلفة
أنا منظومة قيمية، وهو منظومة قيمية
أنا عندي قيم وخبرات
فكل العالمين مختلفة تجي وتندمج وتبدأ تخلق عالم واحد
فهذه الخبرة في البداية دائمًا نقول أعطوها وقتها
عشان كذا كثير نسب الطلاق ممكن تصير هنا، كثير خلافات تصير
لأن كل طرف يتوقع أن الثاني بيصير مثله، وهذا بيصير مثلي
في الحقيقة ما أحد بيصير مثل الثاني
هي مثل الدائرتين ما راح تلتحم مرة ولا تفضل منفصلة مرة
هي بتجي بالنص، ففيه شيء مشترك بنبنيه في النص
وفيه شيء بتحتفظ فيه أنت، وهو بيحتفظ فيه
ما أقدر أنسلخ من كل اللي تربيت عليه، وأجي أخلق شيء جديد
أنا إنسان في الأخير، أحمل كل خبراتي وتجاربي
كذلك الطرف الثاني
فهذا الديناميك اللي يصير في البداية
هذا الالتحام والالتقاء، قد إيه نتداخل، قد أيش نحتفظ
هذه كلها فرص تخلينا نكتشف نفسنا
تخلينا نكتشف الطرف الثاني
إلى أي مدى أقدر أعتمد عليه مثلًا
فين مواطن قوته في هذه العلاقة؟
هي نفسها ممكن تكون مواطن القوة لما يكون والد
هذه عادة تأخذ مدة أشهر، سنوات؟
يعتمد قد إيه احنا راح نكون واعين
وموضحين البوصلة وعندنا هذه الساحة
فيه اثنين ممكن يتزوجوا سنين أصلًا ما ينتبهوا على هذه الأمور
هي في عالم وهو في عالم مثلًا
أو يتجنبوا هذه الحوارات
أو لما مثلًا تصير مشاكل أو اختلافات وهذا مرة طبيعي
هذه فرصة نستثمرها أن نفهم
ليه تنرفرت من هذا الموقف؟
ليه آذاني هذا الشيء؟ ليه جرحني؟
ففيه ناس ما تعطي، عارف اللي بس كذا الحياة ماشية بدون ما نركز
هذول اللي بيطول معهم الموضوع
لكن ممكن يكونوا زوجين على قدر من الوعي والتركيز والاستبصار
وعندهم ساحة أن هم يخصصوا جلسات دائمًا بجودة عالية
أن هم يتكلموا في هذه الأمور كلها
ممكن موضوع ما ياخذ معهم أسابيع، شهور
مرة ثانية، هي ماهي بالكم هي بالكيف
فيه دراسات تقول أن نسبة رضا الزوجين عن العلاقة الزوجية تقل بعد الإنجاب
أيش اللي يحصل في هذه المرحلة، وكيف يمكن يعالجونها؟
كيف يكون الشكل الصحي في هذا الانتقال من دور زوجين إلى دور أبوين؟
وهذه نرجع مرة ثانية لمراحل الأسرة
الآن هذه المرحلة الأولى، طالما دخل الطفل في حياتك
أنت يفترض تنتقل من هذه المحطة وهذه المرحلة للمرحلة الثانية
بعض الأزواج ما ينتقلوا، يفضل قاعد هنا، وطرف راح هناك
فعشان كذا يقول أحسها بعدت عني، أحسه تغيّر عليّ
هو قاعد في محطة وأنتِ في محطة، مثلًا
فهم ما يستوعبوا طبيعة كل محطة أو كل مرحلة
لأن كل مرحلة لها متطلباتها، لها احتياجاتها، لها تحدياتها
فبالتالي لما ما نكون مع بعض في هذه المرحلة
طبعًا يشعروا بالوحدة، بالتغيير
وهذا اللي بالضبط اللي أنت قلته يصير فيه عدم رضا
وطبيعي يصير عدم رضا إذا ما انتقلنا مع بعض لهذه المرحلة
فهذا هو المؤشر لما ما نكون منتقلين على نفس المرحلة
طبعًا وحدة من أسبابها اللي يخلي طرف واحد ما ينتقل لهذه المرحلة
أنه يبغى يحافظ على كل أجواء هذه المرحلة
بس في الحقيقة شئت أم أبيت خلّصت ذي المرحلة
طالما شرّف الطفل؛ خلاص أنت راح تنتقل هناك
وهذا يعكس اللي احنا نسميها قدرات نفسية عند الإنسان
المرونة النفسية، الصلابة، التوافق النفسي هذه كلها
وهذه تنمو مع الخبرات يا عبدالرحمن
أنا ممكن مرونتي في أول مرحلة في محطة الأسرة هذه
تكون محدودة، لكن مع هذه الخبرات والتحديات والصعوبات
تزيد عندي المرونة وأطلع
فلا نتخيل أن المهارات النفسية تجعل البساط أحمر مفروش
وللا بساط وردي، لا هي تمر بصعوبات
لذلك لو طالعنا كلنا على حياتنا، وعملنا تصغير
وللا طالعت وراء على حياتي؛ أنا أمتن للحظات الصعبة أو للتحديات
لأن هي اللي ترفع عندنا الإمكانيات النفسية والمهارات
هذه كمان أحد القناعات اللي نحتاج أن نُعمّمها
أن الوقت الصعب هذا، مشاعر الغير رضا اللي تمر فيها
هذه خبرة لك للتعلم، للنمو وللنضج
أيش اللي يتغيّر على الطرفين؟
أيش التوقعات اللي تختلف وتخلي الحياة تكون سيئة؟
أيش اللي تغير عليهم؟ كل شيء
وأنت بكرامة الحمام يتغيّر عليهم
أسأل الأمهات، تقول لك أنا ما أقدر أدخل للحمام مثلًا
لأن الطفل يبكي طول الوقت
مثلًا لما ما يكون أحد معها، تستنى زوجها يجي
عشان أقدر آخذ دش براحتي
أضمن أن فيه أحد معاه
النوم يختلف، ممكن ما يلاقوا وقت يأكلوا فيه
الوقت اللي كان للمتعة أسهر على فلم ما أقدر
بسهر مع هذا الطفل، بالذات لو مِرض أو بدأ يسنن
أو غيره من أي تحديات. فأشياء كثير تتغير عليهم
وشوف مهما كنا متوقعين
دائمًا احنا عارفين أن نومكم بيتغيّر
بس لما نعيشه؛ ذيك الساعة بيكون مختلف تمامًا عن ما سمعناه
فأشياء كثير تتغيّر
كنتِ تقولين يجب على الطرفين يعرفوا الانتقال إلى أدوار جديدة
وكذلك التنازلات
أيش شكل التنازلات الصحية اللي تحصل بين الزوجين؟
يعتمد، أنا دائمًا أقول كل عائلة فريدة من نوعها
وكل إنسان فريد من نوعه، وهذا مهم
أنا من الأشياء اللي أشعر أن هي من...
خلينا نقول الطرح الإعلامي الغير مكتمل أو المشوّه أو ماهو متزن
أن نحط واحد، اثنين، ثلاثة
أن احنا نعلّب الخطوات أو نحدّد الأشياء
أنا عن أيش أتنازل؟
حقيقةً تفرق من شخص لشخص
وهنا ترجع لإمكانياتنا
وعشان كذا نرجع مرة ثانية، أعرف نفسك
كلما عرفت نفسك؛ كلما عرفت تجاوب على هذه الأسئلة
أسوأ شيء لما مثلًا أطلع كمختص في الإعلام وأقول
أتنازل عن نومك، عن أصدقائك، عن عملك
طيب، يمكن هذه الثلاثة بالنسبة لي أنا رفاهية وكماليات
ولشخص آخر هي أساسيات
أنا يمكن عملي لو أتنازلت عنه ما راح يأثر
بس عند أم ثانية ممكن يهز مثلًا بناء اقتصادي كبير في أسرتها
لذلك ما نقدر نعمم
وهذه نصيحتي لكل أب وأم
من يوم ما تشوفوا حلول جاهزة انتبهوا
لأن شكلها مريح في البداية، شكلها مريح
قالوا لي واحد، اثنين، ثلاثة
واحنا صرنا بزمن سرعة، نبغي كله اصلاح سريع
أعطيني واحد، اثنين، ثلاثة
في الحقيقة ما نقدر نعطي حلول جاهزة
فعن أيش أتنازل؟
اختبر نفسك، أسأل نفسك
أنا ممكن اليوم مثلًا أتنازل عن النوم
بس بعدين ألاقي أن ضعف النوم مرة بيجهد صحتي
فبالتالي ما بقدر أتنازل عن النوم، فبطلب مساعدة مثلًا
الإجابة دائمًا نقول أن كل واحد بيعرف يجاوب هذا السؤال
لو تواصل مع نفسه
هل يتفقوا على الأدوار هذه قبل الإنجاب؟
وللا يتفقوا عليها مثل ما تجي؟
الاثنين، دائمًا نقول كلما كان فيه حوارات مفتوحة
تكلمنا وفكرنا بصوت عالي مع بعض كشركاء
مريح لأن أنت بتفكر
حتى لو ما صار، حتى لو حطينا خطة
وحسينا أنه خططنا وبعدين تفاجأنا
طلع هذا الطفل طول وقت ما ينام بالليل
ممكن يفاجأك الطفل ينام طول الليل
فأنت نومك مرتاح ما يحتاج تتنازل عنه
فبالتالي هي الإجابة
هذا الطفل من الجنة، مو موجود
لا، فيه
والله؟
أنا وحدة من بناتي كذا جات
ما شاء الله
بس في المقابل النهار ما تنام
ربك ما يجمع عسرين
سبحان الله، عشان كذا أرجع أقول أن احنا نخطط
بعدين ما تعرف، الظروف تجي
فالمرونة هي المطلوبة
أن احنا بنفكر مع بعض بصوت عالي
بس كمان خلي عندك مرونة بما يكفي
أن تستقبل أي مفاجآت ممكن تصير لك أو أي تغييرات
نسبة عدم الرضا هذه اللي تحصل بعد تحولهم إلى والدين
هي سببها اختلاف توقعات؟
وللا كيف نقدر نقلل من هذا الانزعاج، ونحوله إلى علاقة قوية متينة؟
عندنا نظرية مرة تسهل الصورة هذه
هذا الواقع، وكلما كان التوقع بعيد عن الواقع
فهذه المسافة الكبيرة بينهم تتعبأ بمشاعر مزعجة
فأنا لو هذا واقعي، ما في نوم، ما في وقت للأصدقاء
ما في وقت للنادي، وأنا عندي توقع أني بحافظ عن النادي
وبستمر أروح خميسية أصحابي
فهذا التوقع وهذا الواقع
لو بعدت بينهم المسافة وما صاروا يتشابهوا
بيتعبأ بإحباط وغضب وانزعاج؛ وبالتالي لا رضى
لكن أنا لو قرّبت المسافة بينهم قدر المستطاع
هنا ذيك الساعة أنا أقلل من هذه المشاعر
فلذلك دائمًا نقول، أيش واقعك وأيش توقعاتك
الشيء الآخر، وهذه كثير من الأهل
لما يدخلوا في بدايات مرحلة الأطفال والإنجاب وكذا
يحسب أن كذا الحياة بتكون، لا
هذا اللي ما ينيّمك؛ بيجي يوم ينام طول الوقت
لما يوصل في المراهقة، وتروح أصلًا تتضارب ما عشان يصحى
الحياة مراحل، وكل شيء مؤقت، وكل شيء له وقته
فأنا اليوم لو مثلًا ما قدرت أمارس الرياضة كما كنت قبل الإنجاب
هذا لا يعني أننا العمر كله كذا
بس مرات الإنسان، وهذه واحدة من التشوهات الفكرية
اللي نقول أننا ننتبه عنها؛ التعميم، التضخيم
إذا اليوم أنا انحرمت من النوم في أول كم شهر؛ فهذه مسألة وقت
بيكبر الطفل وأرجع أنام وأرتاح
فهذا اللي نحتاج نعرفه
هذه وحدة من الأشياء اللي تصيب كثير من الأمهات والآباء
اللي هي الـ«فومو» الخوف من الضياع
يحس أن هذا الطفل جاء، وضيّع عليّ أشياء كثير
ضيّع عليّ فرص تعليمية، ضيع عليّ فرص وظيفية
ضيع عليّ متعة أو غيره
هذا مؤقت
هذا الشيء لو فقدته الآن
لا يصير عندي خوف من الضياع أو بيروح عليّ
هو بيروح عليك نعم دحين، بس لا يعني أنه راح للأبد
لاحق بتقدر
استيعاب المرحلة، تقبّل المرحلة مثل ماهي
نعيش المرحلة مثل ماهي
كثير من الآباء يكون هو جسديًّا في مرحلة
بس دهنيًّا قاعد في مرحلة ثانية
أيش تقصدين؟
مثلًا أنا الآن أكون أب لطفل عمره سنتين
بيحتاج تواجد جسدي، يحتاج تواجد عاطفي وغيره
لكن هو جالس في مرحلة ذهنية
أن أنا لازم أتواجد مثلًا في هذا المشروع وقت مرة أطول
فبالتالي هنا تختل الموازين
طيب، المرحلة تتطلب أنه كمان تواجد هنا، كيف أوفق بينهم؟
لو أخّرت هذا المشروع مثلًا سنة بس
مرة ثانية، شوف ما في إجابات مثالية
أعرف أني ما بجلس من برج عاجي، فيه فرص تجي ما تروح
بس نقول نحسبها على كل الأبعاد
لأن نفس الشيء، هذا العمر لو راح؛ ما راح يرجع
إذا ما فيه إجابة مثالية، بس هل فيه بوصلة؟
هل فيه قاعدة ذهبية؟ هل فيه شيء أرجع له؟
هذا اللي أنا لازم أوصل له
كيف؟ الطريق يختلف من شكل لآخر، من شخص لآخر، من حالة لحالة
بس هل فيه شيء أنا أتجه له؟
استيعاب طبيعة المرحلة، هذا اللي يمكن يساعدني
مثلًا، لو يعرف الآباء والأمهات أن 80% من أدمغة الأطفال
تنموا بعد الولادة في أول سنتين
سبحان الله، هذا الجزء الوحيد من الإنسان اللي يكتمل بعد الولادة
الرئة تكتمل قبل الولادة، القلب والأجهزة كلها
ما عذا الدماغ، ليش؟
لأنه يحتاج إلى تفاعل عاطفي واجتماعي
وهذا يصير جزء بسيط منه أثناء وجوده في الرحم
الطفل يخزّن الأصوات
عشان كذا يقول لك الحالة النفسية اللي تمر فيها الأم أثناء الحمل
تأثر بشكل مباشر على الطفل
ولكن لما يطلع الطفل لهذه الدنيا
هو أول سنتين 80% - 90% من دماغه يكتمل بهذا التواصل
فبالتالي، سبحان الله، عجيب
أنا واحدة من الأشياء اللي أفزعتني لما درست علم النفس العصبي
لما شوفنا مقارنة أدمغة الأطفال في أول سنتين
اللي عندهم تواجد عاطفي، اللي الأم تطالع في عيونه ويناغي وترد معاه
اللي تمسك جسمه، اللي تضحك له، اللي تشجعه وتتكلم معاه
سبحان الله، لو تشوف النواقل العصبية وشكل الدماغ
تحسه كذا منتعش مكتمل
بينما الأطفال اللي اُهملوا، اللي ما في أحد يطالع في عيونهم
اللي يقول بس خلوه يبكي لا تشيلوه
لا تعودوه على الشيء، لا يتدلع
اللي بس يأكله ويشربه وقاعد على سريره
والأطفال اللي قعدوا في دور الأيتام وقت طويل
وبس كانوا يطالعوا في السقف
هذه أشكال أدمغتهم لو تشوفها مخيفة
أصغر حجمًا، وأقل بالنشاط العصبي
وهذا النشاط العصبي احنا بحاجة له عشان يكتمل نمو الدماغ
فكثير من العمليات العقلية
اللي على عمر كبير نستخدمها، هي تنشأ في هذاك العمر الصغير
هي تتأسس في هذاك العمر
فهذه المعلومة وحدها كافية عشان تخليني أعرف
أنني لو اليوم مثلًا أجّلت هذا البحث اللي أشتغل عليه
وللا أجّلت هذا المشروع؛ عشان أعمل هذا التواصل
العاطفي الإجتماعي وأعطيه وقته
أنا هنا راح أعرف، صح أنا ما أشوفه بالعين المجردة
بس هذا عطاء ورعاية راح يخدم هذا الإنسان لما يكبر
أنا راح أعطيه نمو متكامل فيه
أيش شكل الرعاية؟ وأيش الشكل المثالي لي كأب وأم
في السنة الأولى أو سنتي الأولى، أيش أسوي معاه؟
أتكلم معاه؟ أشيله؟
شوف احنا نلخصها...
لأن فيه ناس تسوي أشياء كثيرة، وكل شوي تطلع لك سالفة
طبعًا أنت بتضيع ما بين نصايح أهلك
وما بين نصايح اللي تشوفها على الإنستقرام
الظاهر أني شفت مقطع قريب، ناس كانوا يتنمروا على واحد
ناسي المقطع بالضبط، كان أب يشيل طفله كان يرضعه
بس الفكرة علشان يقول لك هذا التواصل، أيش يسموه؟
الجسدي، التلامس الجسدي؟
إيه التلامس الجسدي
ففيه ناس كانوا يقولوا مساكين ما يعرفوا أن هذا كذا
وفيه ناس يقولون أيش جالس يسوي، مثل كذا
بس سالفة تصير في إنستقرام
فهل تروح تسويها وللا لا؟ والله ما عاد صرت أدري
فعطيني السنتين الأولى، أيش اللي مفترض أنا أسويه مع طفلي كطرفين؟
شوف هي احنا نلخصها في ثلاثة كلمات: تواصل، رعاية، تواجد
طبعًا هو أسهل شيء لما نقول التواجد، يعني أنا أكون موجود جنبه
هذا ما يكفي
أنا ممكن أكون جنبه وقاعد على جوالي طول الوقت
هذا ماهو تواجد
وهذه كلها الثلاثة تكمّل بعض؛ التواجد والتواصل والرعاية
فالتواجد العاطفي، كيف أكون أنا متواجدة عاطفيًّا مع هذا الطفل
حاضرة عاطفيًّا وأتواصل عاطفيًّا
أعطيك تجربة صارت، وهذه مرة معروفة
يمكن أي أحد من المتابعين يدور عليها
وصارت وتكررت، يسموها الوجه الجامد
وهذه رائعة التجربة وتلخص كثير، وتعطيك الإجابة بالضبط
هذه التجربة صارت، جابوا طفل عمره ستة إلى ثمانية شهور
هذا اللي احنا نقول ما يفهم، وأيش أسوي معاه
طلبوا من الأم أن تتواجد وتتفاعل معاه عاطفيًّا
فهي تضحك، هو يضحك معاها، مرآة للمشاعر
هو يناغي، هي تناغي، تطالع في عيونه، وهي حاضرة عاطفيًّا معاه
الآن هو مبسوط وأنا مبسوطة
فكان فيه تواصل عاطفي معاه
بعدين طلبوا من الأم شي واحد بس يا عبدالرحمن
أن هي بس تكون ولا شيء، مشاعر جامدة
عشان كذا هي اسمها الوجه الجامد
فطلبوا منها بس يكون وجهها جامد
فهي دارت وجهها ورجعت ثاني وجهها جامد، ما في أي مشاعر
أيش صار في الطفل؟
عجيب لو تتأمل وجه الطفل، في البداية كان مستغرب
بعدين شوية بدأ يرتبك الطفل، ما في مشاعر، ما في حضور
هذا ثمانية الشهر؟
هذا الثمانية شهور
واو!
أزيدك شوق مو بس كذا
صار يحاول يلعبها، صار هو يحط جهد أن تواجدي
صار يأشر بيده، ويحاول يطلع أصوات
وهذا هو الجهد النفسي اللي يصير كثير من الأطفال
أنهم يحاولوا يتواصلوا
سبحان الله، الإنسان مولود بفطرته وقادر على التواصل
هو بس يحتاج الطرف الثاني يشبك معاه
عشان يكمل هذا التواصل
فصار يحاول يتواصل معها بشكل لطيف
بعد كذا بان عليه الخوف، وبدأ يرتبك ويبكي
على طول الأم طبعًا رجعت احتضنته وهدأ
فاحنا أيش نفهم من هذه التجربة؟
أن عدم التواجد، لما يكون حاجز من مشاعرنا
لما أنا أطالع في الولد وما عندي مشاعر حاضرة معاه
ما أتفاعل مع مشاعره
فأنت ما تتخيل كمية الإرباك
أقول لهم احنا لو نشوف أدمغة الأطفال، شفافة
ترى عجيبة النواقل العصبية اللي تصير
شوف كيف لما نخاف؛ منطقة المشاعر في الدماغ
تبدأ تنشط بطريقة مربكة، الدماغ يقول لك فيه شيء غلط
لما أنا أبكي، وأمي برّا الغرفة، تقول ما بدخل عشان أعلّمه ينام وحده
وهو عمره شهور
الارتباك اللي يبدأ يصير والحالة العاطفية
تبدأ تشكّل عند الطفل أنه ما أحد موجود
أنا مو مهم، ما أحد يسمعني، أنا ما أحد فاهم احتياجاتي
أنا احتياجاتي مو مهمة
بعدين تقول لك بعد ثلاثة أسابيع صار ينام لوحده
لأنه تعلّم من عمر صغير أن ما في أحد عشاني، ما أحد بيفهمني
الطفل الذي يبكي بزيادة بصوت عالي
هو يسوّي كذا لأنه يحس أن ما أحد فاهمني
أنا بعلِّ العيار عشان تفهموني
فبالتالي، دائمًا نقول ما نبغى أبناءنا يوصل لهذا الجهد العاطفي
مثل هذه التجربة، شفت كيف ارتبك وخاف
هذا جهد نفسي ما المفروض يعيش الطفل بقدر المستطاع
فتواجدنا والرعاية
والشيء الجميل، سبحان الله، وهذا عدالة ورحمة الله
أن هذا التواجد والتواصل تراه ببلاش
ما يتطلب أنك تكون غني وأنك مثقف وأنك شيء
كل اللي تحتاجه عيون للتواصل، تلامس جسدي
التلامس الجسدي، هذا كثير صارت عليها دراسات
بالذات أول ما يتولد
أنا ولدت طفلتين في أمريكا، الأولى كانت قبل إحدى عشر سنة
كان اختياري التلامس الجسدي في المستشفيات
الثانية اللي عمرها سبعة سنين، كان إجباري
إذا الأم ما عندها عرض صحي أو اكتئاب ما بعد الولادة
إجباري يحطونه ملامسة جسدية، ليش؟
لأن، سبحان الله، درجة حرارة الطفل تنتظم لما يلامس جلده جلد الأم
نبضات قلبه تنتظم لما يصير فيه هذا الالتصاق
الطفل لما يلتصق هو مو بس تلامس جسدي
هو بيشم ريحتها، بيسمع نفسها، بيحس أن أنا آمن
أنا فيه إنسان بيحتويني
فهذا الالتصاق قاعد ينشّط الدماغ عنده
وقاعد يشكّل عنده شعور اتجاه نفسه جميل
أنا محبوب، أنا مرغوب، أنا مفهوم، أنا مهم
وهذه هي اللبنة الأولى للبناء النفسي السليم
اللي هي تجي بعدين ثقة بالنفس واتزان وأمان وتواصل سليم
الحين هذا التواجد، بس أنتِ كل اللي قلتيه هو بالنسبة للأم
بالنسبة للأب؟
نفس الشيء، أنا لما أقول طالع في عيونه وناغي وكذا
هذه كمان للأب، نفس الشيء
أنت ما يحتاج تحضر دورات، أنت طالع في وجهه وناغيه
وهذا كلنا بشكل عام وأغلبنا نسويها
بس لما افهم أن نظرة العين والتواصل والملامسة الجسدية
هي ماهي دلع أو ماهو بس أنا بسلّيه
أنا جالس أنشّط دماغه، أنا جالس بخلّي دماغه لمولود 20% يشتغل
أخليه 80% إلى 90% يكتمل
هذه الثواني من التواصل هي ماهي بس كذا تسلية
هي فيها بناء عصبي، جسدي، روحي، عاطفي
وأنت بتحط اللبنات الأولى في هذا البناء النفسي لهذا الإنسان
فبالتالي هذه اللحظة بتصير جدًّا مقدرة، جدًّا غالية عليك كأب أو أم
بس أنتِ تقولي هذا مجانًا، بس ما أتوقع أنه مجانًا
لأنه يجي على حساب، مثلًا إذا الأب تلقاه يشتغل
ثمان ساعات أو اثنا عشر ساعة، أو حتى ممكن الأم بتشتغل
بعدين يرجعون منهكين
فكيف الواحد يتعامل معها في ظروف هذه الحياة الصعبة؟
يكون إنسان. أنا أرجع أقول مرة ثانية
طيب أنا أشتغل ثمانية ساعات، برجع البيت
ما أصدق أي أب يقول أنا ما عندي وقت
لو حقيقي ما عندك وقت، معناته ما عندك وقت لا لتويتر ولا إنستقرام
إذا مسكت جوالك ودخلت على هذه التطبيقات؛ معناته أنت عندك وقت
إذا أنت بتفتح الواتساب؛ معناته عندك وقت
لا نقول أن ما في وقت
ومرة ثانية يا عبدالرحمن، هي كيف وليس كم
مثلًا تقول الأم أنا ثمانية ساعات في الشغل
بس ارجع البيت ما عندي إلا أربع ساعات معاهم
لو هذه الأربع ساعات فيها جودة عالية وتواصل جيد
معناتها هي كافية، مو ضروري أنا أقعد ثمانية ساعات في الشغل
وأجلس مع أبنائي ثمانية ساعات. فهي هذه الفكرة
احنا اليوم مرة نشتغل بلغة الأرقام وهذا غلط
هذا اللي أفقدنا إنسانيتنا. فهذا رقم واحد
رقم اثنين، لما قلت أنا أرجع مجهدة من العمل
سواءً الأب أو الأم، ممتاز ارجع مجهد من العمل
وعادي لا تحاول تكون مثالي أمام أبناءك
لا تدخل كأنك مكينة ترفع أعلى العيارات في السعادة وفي النشاط
خلِّ أبناءك يشوفوك جاي منهك، تحتاج ترتاح
وبترجع لهم مرة ثانية
فهذا التواصل الصحي السليم مع أنفسنا
وأن احنا نبيّن محدودياتنا وقوتنا، ضعفنا وقوتنا
سعادتنا وحزننا، اجهادنا وعافيتنا
هذا يبيّن لهم أن احنا بشر
فهم لما يكبروا يتعلموا من هذه النمذجة
أنك عادي تكون تعبان، وعشانك تعبان لازم ترتاح
فيفهم الطفل أنه بيحتاج ...
مرة ثانية نرجع لتجربة الوجه الجامد
هو فهم أن أمه فيها شيء غلط وحاول
فأطفالنا يفهموا
يفهموا من متى؟
من أول ما يتولدوا
من أول ما يتولدوا؟
من أول ما يتولدوا نعم
ترى دراسات كثيرة، عشان ما أبغى آخذ وقت طويل فيها
الطفل يفهم المعاني الفيزيائية من عمره أربعة شهور
فيه دراسات صارت عجيبة جدًّا
شفت مفهوم الجاذبية في الفيزياء؟
الطفل مولود فاهمه
فيه تجارب كثير صارت لأطفال، ورّوهم مثل قطعة المكعب تمشي وتطيح
فشافوا نظرة العين والعمليات العقلية
يعني حطوا أسلاك لأدمغة الأطفال
فالعمليات اللي بتصير أنه تمام طاح
بعدين جابوا ستارة ومشوا المكعب فوق الطاولة
خلّصت الطاولة، بس فيه واحد ماسك المكعب من وراء هذا ومشّاها
الطفل نظرته صارت أطول والعمليات العقلية صارت في الدماغ أشد
فكأنه بيقول هذه ليه ما طاحت
وهذا عمره خمسة أو ستة شهور. فالطفل يدرك
أعطيك مثال، لو طفل عمره شهور تلفّت وأنت في مطعم مثلًا
وطالعت فيه وسويت له مع السلامة
بيفضل يطالع فيك صح؟ هذا أيش يعطيه؟
أنا أفهم أنك أنت الآن تتواصل معايا
أنا فاهم أنك أعطيتني وجه، وأنا بردها لك بابتسامة
احنا دائمًا نشعر أن هم إنسان غير مكتمل
هو مكتمل وقادر على التواصل وفاهم
فمتى يفهم؟ هو نازل على ذي الدنيا فاهم
ومفترض أتكلم معاه؟ من متى؟
من تواجده في الرحم
يخزن الطفل في رحم الأم كثير من الأصوات
أنا ما أعطيك بس دراسات، أنا تجربة شخصية صارت لي
أنا بنتي الأولى كنت في تهيئة عشان الثانية جاية
فآخر ثلاثة شهور في حملي كان عندنا قصة مفضلة
اسمها «الأخوات الكبار هم المفضلين» (big sisters are the best)
القصة كانت من باب التهيئة أيش يعني أخت كبيرة
ولما يجي الطفل وماما تصير مشغولة
وكنا نقرأها مرة كثير
لما طلعت من المستشفى، ما أنسى هذا الموقف
بنتي الثانية كان عمرها ساعات، 48 ساعة كان عمرها
فكانت في حضني، وبنتي الكبيرة جابت نفس القصة
«الأخوات الكبار هم المفضلين» (big sisters are the best)
فأول ما فكيت القصة قلت «الأخوات الكبار هم المفضلين»
لينا كانت في حضني دارت وجهها على ناحية أختها
وحركتها هدأت أكثر، وكأنها بتستمع للقصة
وكلما كانت تكبر؛ كنا من يومها نقول «الأخوات الكبار هم المفضلين»
تهدأ وتسمع للقصة
فهذا يعطيك انطباع، أن هو مألوف عليها هذه القصة
كثير من الناس مثلًا تقول لك أغنية طفلي المفضلة
قرآن مثلًا شيخ معين يهدأ فيه
كانت الأم تشغّل هذا الشيخ مثلًا وهي حامل
فنعم دراسات كثير أثبتت والواقع يقول لنا هذا الشيء
أن الأصوات تُخزّن
احنا دائمًا نعتقد أن عشان هو ما يتجاوب معانا لفظيًّا وكلاميًّا
هو ما يفهم، بس مو عشان ما عنده مقدرة على التواصل اللفظي
هو ما عنده مقدر على التواصل
التواصل جزء منه لفظي والأغلب غير لفظي
صح. في السنتين الأولى وناخذ هذه المرحلة
عادةً ما يكون فيه مشكلة عند الأب أنه ما يعرف أيش دوره
إذا الأم واضحة لحدٍ ما أو كبير دورها
الأب أيش دوره في هذه المرحلة؟
هذه ثقافة مجتمعية. شكرًا مرة على سؤالك
لأن للأسف احنا عندنا ثقافة مجتمعية أن الأم، الأم
والأب تقريبًا...
الأم مدرسةٌ إذا أعددتها
هذه من الأشياء اللي بندفع ضريبتها
فبالتالي، أعطت الإذن للأب أن أنت فصل منت مدرسة
أنا مشرف أصلًا
فعلًا، هذه العبرة الثانية الثقافة
للأسف أن أنت عبارة عن مكينة صرف
أو أنت بس اللي تسلّي
فمرة ثانية نقول، اللي تعمله الأم في أول سنتين التواصل البصري
أنه يشيل الطفل أو غيره، هو نفس الشيء أنت تعمله
نفس الشيء مثلًا إذا تبغى تأكّله، هي نفسها
نفس الممارسات اليومية اللي تصير
وهذه يفترض أنها تصير بالمناصفة، أو بلاش نقول مناصفة
بس مو دائمًا الأم هي وظيفتها اللي تنيّم الطفل
لو الأب يقدر كمان ينيّمه؛ مريح
لأن ممكن الأم في يوم من الأيام تتعب أو تمرض
أو تضطر مثلًا تروح إلى أي ظرفٍ كان تطلع من البيت
فالطفل هذا ما يضيع، مو الأب يجلس عاجز
وهذا اللي يصير
كثير من الآباء يحسوا أن أنا عاجز ما أعرف أنيمه، ما أعرف أأكله
وهذا ممكن يكون أحد أسبابه؛ خطأ من الأم
شالت الليلة كلها، أن أنا اللي بنيّم، أنا اللي بسوي
فسحبت المسؤوليات بشكل غير مباشر
ويمكن بحسن النية من الأب
لكن مهم التعاون
فيه دراسة مرة جميلة كان اسمها
الأم كأنها حارس المرمى في لعب الآباء مع الأطفال
الدراسة تقول أن الراحة العاطفية والفيزيائية في اللعب مع الآباء
أعلى بكثير من الأمهات
وأن تواجد الأم وقت لعب الأب مع أولاده
يخلي لعبهم يصير محدود، ليش؟
لأن الأمهات دائمًا عندهم التنظيم عالي
لا تكركبوا، لا ترموا، لا تشخمطوا
فالطفل دائمًا يحس أنه ممكن مقيّد
بسبب كثرة المسؤوليات على الأم
لكن لما يكون مع الأب يصير عنده راحة أكثر
وهذه الدراسة من التوصيات حقها باختصار
يقولوا للأم سيبي الأب في حاله مع الأولاد
أطلعي أنتِ من الصورة وخليه
خليه يحوس، خليه يلعب
مو لازم يمشي بالمنهجية حقتك
وهذه وحدة من الأمور اللي نقولها
مو لازم نتشابه كآباء وأمهات في التربية
بعض الأمهات تقول لك يلعب معاهم ألعاب خطيرة يخوّف
طيب هو يبغى يلعب كذا، مو لازم يلعب بترتيب مثلك
مو لازم يغسّلوا المكان بعد ما يخلصوا
إذا هم يبغوا يسووا فوضى
تقبّل اختلافاتنا كمان، ونعطي مساحة للأب
حقيقي الآباء مرات ما بياخذوا هذه المساحة في مجتمعنا
وصحي للطفل أن يكون هذا التباين في التربية ما بين الأب والأم؟
أيوة، التباين حقيقة بين البشر
والطفل ذكي جدًّا
أنا متأكدة الآن لو الأمهات والأبهات يسمعوني عارفين
يعرفوا الولد لما يبغى شيء من جده كيف يطلبه
مو مثل لما نطلبه من أبوه
عارف جده كيف يجيب رأسه، وبابا كيف اعرف اتكلم معاه
الطفل قادر
الأطفال شخصياتهم في المدارس مو مثل في البيت؛ تختلف، ليه؟
لأن الطفل يدرك أن أنا الآن في بيئة مختلفة، فيه تباين
فالطفل مولود وهو مستوعب التباينات هذه
فاحنا ليش نبغى نخلي المثالية كذا، ولازم كله يتشابه؟ لا، عادي
أنتِ قلتِ قبل شوية على سالفة البكاء
إذا بكي فيه ناس تخليه علشان يتعلم
أن البكاء مو حل لتلبية للأشياء اللي هو يبغاها
وفيه ناس تجي تقول، أتذكر مدري وين قريتها، يمكن تغريدة أو شيء
يعرف الطفل أنه بياخذ كل شيء بالبكاء
من أول مرة تشيله عشانه بكى
وخلاص انتهت المسألة
فكيف تتعامل معها؟
أنت ما تبغى الطفل كل شوي يبكي
علشان يبغى حلاوة، يبغى شوكولاتة
يبغى يضحك، يبغى يطلع؛ فيبكي
لأن الحل أنك تقول له يلا أيش نسوي
أنت بتتكلم على أي عمر الآن؟
ما أدري، هو أي عمر اللي يصير فيه هذه المشكلة؟
أول سنتين لغته الوحيدة البكاء
هذه كمان المشكلة، أن أنا أطالع في البكاء
أن هو متضايق أو زعلان أو بيتدلع
بس في الحقيقة ، هو ما بيقدر يتواصل معك بجمل مفيدة وعمره شهور
فطبيعي لما بيتواصل صوتيًا معاك؛ بيطلّع أصوات
وصارت دراسات حتى على نغمات البكاء
مو كل البكاء بكاء، فيه نغمة للجوع، للألم البطن، للنوم، لغيره
مرة ثانية، الأب والأم اللي يكون عندهم حضور وتواصل
يعرفوا يفرقوا في نغمات البكاء
عشان كذا دائمًا نقول لا تشتت نفسك، وتقعد تتابع حساب وحساب
دائمًا نقول أعظم معلم للأب والأم هو الطفل نفسه
احنا دائمًا نقول أعطيني خطوات واحد، اثنين، ثلاثة أيش أسوي
في الحقيقة ما في خطوات
الطفل يولد وكلما تواصلت معاه؛ كلما هو بيعطيك الخطوات
أنت بتعرف مثلًا لما يبدأ يجوع كيف بيحرّك رأسه
كيف بيطلّع النغمة أو غيره
فالبكاء في أول سنتين قبل ما يصير الطفل متمكّن من الكلام
هذا طبيعي، هذا مو دلع
فلو قال وأنت جيت وتواصلت معاه؛ أنا ما بدلّعه
هو بيحاول يوصل لي شيء وأنا تواصلت
فالرسالة اللي توصل للطفل
أن أنا قادر على التواصل هم بيفهموني
فبالتالي يكبر أن أنا مفهوم، أنا بيفهموني الناس
فيه ناس كبار دحين مره يتعبونا في حياتنا مثلًا
أنه يحس أن ما أحد يفهمه، والله بنحاول نفهّمه
لا ما أحد بيفهمني. ونلاقيهم في زوايا كثيرة في الحياة
في العمل يطلع لنا شخص مثل كذا
أشياء كثير نشوف
وهذا ما جاء من فراغ، هذا جاء من عمر قديم
كان يبكي وما أحد يسمع له
كان يبكي ويقول لا تعطوه وجه
فهو فهم في شعور نفسه أن أنا مو مفهوم
أني لازم أصير نكدي عشان يفهموني
لازم أرفع دائمًا صوتي عشان يفهموني
تعرف ذول اللي في الاجتماعات
اللي يا دوبنا بنطرح الموضوع ورفع صوته على طول
ليه ترفع صوتك؟ بنفهمك
بس في الأخير أن أنا مضطر أسوي كذا
لأن بهذه الطريقة أنا سعدت
الطفل من ثلاث إلى خمسة سنوات هي مرحلة تجميع اللغة
ومحاولة التواصل اللفظي
لذلك نقول للأهل إلى خمسة سنوات بيكون خلط
ما بين البكاء، التعبير العاطفي عن البكاء أو الكلام أو اللفظ
وكلما استثمرنا في التواصل اللفظي؛ كلما قل البكاء
طبعًا كيف أعرف؟
نرجع مرة ثانية لسؤالك
أن هذا بكاء دلع، أن هو يبغى يلوِّ ذراعي بالبكاء كل شوية
وأبغى أسكّته بالبكاء
لو كان عندي تواصل وحضور؛ بعرف
أنا مثلًا لو أعرف أنه بنتعشى بعدين بناخذ بسكوت
هو قاعد يسوي لي نكد يبغى البسكوت قبل العشاء، وطلب مني
ما في بسكوت دحين، بعد العشاء
بدأ يطلب، بعدين بدأ يزن، بعدين بدأ يبكي
أنا هنا ما راح أخضع لهذا البكاء
لكن هل بهمله؟ لا
بضربه
ممكن صاحبك هذاك
أيش تسوي طيب معاه؟
التواصل، والتفاعل
هنا احنا نسميها التواصل والتفاعل
كل ما في الموضوع بس اعترف هو أيش يبغى
عشان توصل رسالة، فاهمتك
أنا عارف أن نفسك تاخذ البسكوت
أنا عارف أن مرة نفسك فيه
فهنا أيش الرسالة اللي توصل للطفل؟
أنا فاهمتك، لا يعني بتوافق معاك
وهذه كثير من الأهل يخافوا منها
أن أنا لو اعترفت؛ كأني بمشي له كلامه، لا
كمان الأهل لا بد أن يحافظوا على سلطتهم
ترى الأطفال وهذه دراسات صارت كثير
اللي يتواجدوا في بيئات ما فيها سلطة عليهم، ما في قوانين
ترى هذول من داخلهم مرة مرتبكين
لأن ما في توقعات، ما فيه قوانين
اليوم تفرّج عشرة ساعات آيباد، بكرة فجأة أبوي عصب يشيله مني
لا تتفرجه كثير، بعدين ينسى
هذه الريبة، أنا ما أعرف أيش قوانين البيت
اليوم أكلوني شوكولاتة قبل الأكل، الدولاب مفتوح
بكرة أمي عصبت، شالت علبة الشوكولاتة دسّتها
أنتوا أيش آخرتكم، أنتوا أيش قوانينكم؟
فهذا يربك الطفل
لذلك أنا أثبت على قوانيني
أكون عادي ما أشعر بتأنيب الضمير
ما راح ياكل إلا لما ياكل الأكل المفيد، بعدين أعطيك
بس اعترف للطفل، أنا عارفة أن أنت زعلان
أنا عارفة أنك تبكي أو أنك تبغاه، أنت منزعج
أعطيه مسميات للمشاعر. وهذا كل شيء
ما يحتاج أصلّح الشعور
وأخلّي الشعور يأخذ وقته
هذه واحدة من الأخطاء اللي تصير
أن أنا ما أبغى طفلي يبكي أو يحزن أو يغضب، ليه؟
طيب هو إنسان ماهو علبة بلاستيك
خلوهم يعيشوا مشاعرهم
احنا ننمو من خلال مشاعرنا، فعادي
يصير أنا عندي في ذيك الساعة قدرة أني أتحمل البكاء
خليه عادي يبكي يزن، بيجلس مثل الطيبين ياكل
بعدين نقول له شفت، وأثبت على كلامي
هذه الحلاوة أو هذا البسكوت
بس مين اللي يهلع ويرتبك من بكاء هذا الطفل؟
إذا كان عندنا احنا بداخلنا مشاكل ما انتبهنا لها
معناته بكاءه يحسسني أن أنا ماني جيدة، أنا مو كويسة
طيب من فين جاكِ هذا الصوت؟
معناته إذن عندي مشاكل غير محلولة، ماني منتبهة لها
بس هنا برضه بيتطلب أن القوانين تكون ثابتة ما بين الطرفين؟
يفضّل، أيوة
طبعًا ما نقدر نقول مثاليين
ممكن أنا مثلًا خلصت الساعة 8:00 لازم الساعة 8:00 ننام
يجي الأب بين 8:00 و9:00 ما بسوّي مشكلة ومضاربة
دائمًا نقول المرونة مطلوبة
فيه نقطة مهمة، ممكن ترجع حتى إلى بداية الولادة، في هذا العمر
اللي هي أن الأب والأم يكونوا مشغولين
فعندهم دوام وعمل وكذا
فالحل الموجود هو وجود الخادمة
كيف أثر وجود خادمة على تربية الأطفال؟
وأيش يؤثر على نضجهم وتربيتهم؟
دائمًا احنا نقول إذا بدأنا من العمر المبكر مرة
احنا أفراد أو بالغين حول الطفل لمن يتولد
نسميهم مقدمي الرعاية
مو بالضرورة لازم يكونوا الأب والأم
ممكن أطراف أخرى تدخل كمقدمين الرعاية
أيش مواصفاتهم هذول؟
لازم يكونوا قريبين من الطفل
ما يتغيروا كثير
قريبين بمسافة وللا علاقة؟
كلها، والعلاقة كمان
يكون هذا الشخص قريب ومتواجد
قادر على التواصل مع الطفل، وقادر على الرعاية
وقادر على التواجد
الثلاثة الأركان الأساسية اللي يحتاجها الطفل
فأنا بالتالي لو جاتني عاملة
أخليها تطبخ وتنظف وتكنس، وكمان أمسّكها الطفل!
فأي تواصل ورعاية؟! ما بيصير
فبالتالي، كون أن احنا نستعين بأشخاص
لازم نتأكد أن هذول الأشخاص على قدر جيد من التواصل
فبالتالي، النمط اللي يجلسوا فيه مع الطفل؛ أفرّغهم
ما أجهدهم، ما أعاملها ماكينة
أنت بتنتبهي له وتنظفي وتسوي. هذا جدًّا مهم
فهو ماهو خطأ أن يكون مثلًا فيه شخص كبير
يعتني بالطفل فترة غيابي مثلًا
إذا حسيت أن هذه الخادمة مثلًا ماهي قادرة على التواصل أو غيره
طبعًا هذا لا يعني أني أقول أتركوهم عادي مع الخدم
أنا شخصيًّا أفضّل، أنا لو عليّ ما ينترك أبدًا مع الخدم
وشخصيًّا حتى ما سويتها، الحمد لله
إذا الجدة أو يكون فيه تبادل ما بينهم
بس مش كل الأمهات والآباء عندهم هذا الامتياز
فبالتالي، إذا فيه شخص ممكن يتولى الرعاية؛ يكون ثابت
سبحان الله، هذا يأثر كثير على الطفل
مثلًا «بارني» هذاك الديناصور حق الأطفال
تعرفه وللا لا؟
لا، يمكن لو شفت صورته عرفته
أيوة لونه بنفسجي بالضبط
«بارني» موجود سنوات مرة طويلة
أيوة عرفته، يحط التلفزيون في بطنه أو شيء
شكله لسنين ما تغير، ونفس الصوت
مع أن على فكرة، الرجل اللي يدخل جوّته
مو نفس الشخص لمدة سنين
بس ليش ثابت شكله وصوته؟
عشان الأطفال يرتبطوا بسرعة معاه
وهذا اللي خلّى الأطفال يرتبطوا مع «بارني» ويحبوه
الثبات، عشان كذا شايف نفس نبرة الصوت، نفس الشكل، نفس اللون
عشان كذا ثبات مقدمي الرعاية وتواجدهم؛ هذا مهم
بس هل بيأثّر؟ أيش أثره السلبي إذا كان مثلًا خادمة؟
أولًا الخادمة هي جاية...
لنفترض أن عندها وقت أو فيه وقت كافي
أنها تقدر تسوي هذا وهذا، أو نفرض أنهم ثنتين
ما في سيناريو واحد نقدر نشوفه في الواقع
أنت يمكن تجيب خادمة قلبها رحيم وطيب
وفعلًا تتواجد وتعطي له وقته وتفهم للطفل
تصير حوارات دائمًا بينها وبين الأم
فيصيروا يفهموا على الطفل وقادرين يتواصلوا
فيه ممكن تجيك خادمة، أنا جاية باخذ فلوس من هذه العائلة وبس
فأنا ما عندي لا ارتباط ولا تواصل
ممكن يكون خُلقها ضيق على الطفل، ما تتحمله
وطبعًا هذه هو اللي بيأثر على الطفل
اللي تتعامل معاك كأنه منتج
أنت أعطيتني هو عشان أحفّظ و أغيّر، وما يهمها الطفل
بس هل الطفل يقدر يعرف أن هذه أم و هذه مو بأم؟
أيوة
أيش بيأثر وجود غير الأم باهتمام أكثر من الأم للطفل؟
الطفل يرتبط مع اللي يقدم له رعاية أكثر وتواصل أكثر
وهذه للأسف تصير، تلاقي الأم غايبة تمامًا عن الطفل
ترجع تعبانة، ما لي خلق للطفل
في الأخير هو عبارة عن شيء يجيها جاهز
متحمم، آكل، شارب؛ بس تجلس معه دقيقتين
وبعدين تبغى تنام عشان وراها دوام وغيره
فهو طول الوقت قاعد مع العاملة
فالطفل ارتباطه العاطفي ممكن يكون مع العاملة
أو مع الخادمة في البيت أو مع الجدة
أو مع من يعطيه الرعاية في الأخير
مين يعطينه رعاية؛ برتبط فيه
هذا اللي بيصير للطفل
فهو في البداية ماهو مو مثل احنا كبار، هذه أم
بالنسبة للطفل مين بيعطيني الرعاية؟ هو اللي برتبط معاه
أيش الحلول اللي الحين؟
فيه حل أن أنا أعطي وقتي، وهذا هو الحل الأمثل
بس إذا افترضنا أنه غير موجود؛ فيصير فيه ممكن خادمة
أو أحد مثلًا جدة، بس إذا مو موجود؛ ممكن خادمة
هل فيه حل آخر مثلًا؟
هل الحضانة وللا المدارس الصغيرة اللي تبدأ من أشهر
هي خيار جيد؟
تعتمد حسب مواصفات هذا المكان
النسبة يفترض أن على كل ثلاثة أطفال
واحد يقدم الرعاية في هذا العمر الصغير
وهذه النسبة مثلًا معتمدة في السويد
أو في دول اللي رعاية الطفل عندهم عالية وقوانينها مرة محددة
فممنوع أن أكثر من ثلاثة اللي هو في عمر السنتين يكون معه
لكن للأسف مرات احنا مش هذا دائمًا الخيار اللي موجود
الخيار الموجود تدخل كذا كأنه قدر في شارع نسميها
تلاقي فيه عشرين طفل واثنين عليهم
الطفل المسكين حاسس أن أنا موجود في ذا المكان
بس عشان يغيّروا لي الحفاض ويشربوني بس
وقاعد أسمع صوات بكاء حواليني وأطفال
فما هو خيار كثير صراحة
صدقًا أعرف أن هذه الكلمة ممكن توجع قلب
كثير من الآباء والأمهات لأن أبناءهم يكونوا في هذا، بس لا
الشيء الثاني، المُدرسة ممكن تتغير
أنا اليوم لو طفل عندي ذول المدرستين
بعدين مناوبة يجوا اثنين، بعدين هذه المعلمة غابت
بعدين هذه قدمت استقالة جات ثانية
فما نضمن ثبات مقدمي الرعاية اللي يصيروا عليهم
الشيء الثاني، الطفل لما الأم تختفي فترة طويلة
هو ما يفهم أن هي راحت شغل وجات
فيه دراسات قرأتها، أن الطفل يعتقد أن الأم اختفت، ماتت
فبالنسبة له أسود وأبيض، هي موجودة أو مو موجودة
فيصير فيه خوف عندهم
أيش الحل؟
عشان كذا نقول يفضّل أن في أول سنتين
يكون في نفس بيئة البيت
يكون شخص واحد ثابت عليه، أو يكون الجدة مثلًا
أو ممكن احنا ثلاثة سيدات عاملات
مثلًا نتفق أننا نجيب وحدة ونستأجرها
هذه أفكار ما أعرف ليش ناس كثير كمان ما تطبقها
البيت تظل بيئة أنظف، أأمن، أهدى
فممكن هذه تكون فكرة
أن أنا أتفق مع أحد يقدم الرعاية لهذول الثلاثة
وخلاص يصير حتى الطفل ما يقعد في مواصلات
وأنا ما أكون كأم ولا أب أوصّل وأجيب، وهذا إجهاد علينا
بالنسبة للرضاعة الطبيعية والغير طبيعية
تفرق في تفاعل الطفل مع الأم؟
إلا تفرق
الرضاعة الطبيعية، سبحان الله، عجيبة جدًّا
أولًا معدة الطفل إلى ستة شهور تكون غير قادرة
على استقبال مركبات أو أشياء خارجية
حليب الأم عجيب، سبحان الله
احنا لو بس جينا على تركيبة الحليب
أول شيء، سبحان الله، تطلع كميات كبيرة نسبة الموية فيها أعلى
بعدين يبدأ نسبة السكر تزيد شوية مع عملية الرضاعة من الطفل
فالسكر يبدأ يحفز الشهية عند الطفل
بعدين، سبحان الله، نفس الحليب يبدأ يزيد نسبة الدهون
عشان يبدأ ياخذ الدهون ويشبع
لما أن الطفل يبدأ يشبع، فيه افرازات من فمه
تلتقي مع، سبحان الله، ثدي الأم
فيبدأ يعرف الثدي أن هذا يبدأ يشبع؛ فيبدأ يخرّج موية
تخيل هذا الترتيب؛ عمرك ما بتسويه في الرضاعة الصناعية
تطلّع موية في البداية، خاص كله موية وحليب بقري
فهذا الترتيب العجيب، سبحان الله
غير كذا أنه خفيف على المعدة، يزيد المناعة بشكل كبير
دراسات كثيرة بيّنت، سبحان الله، أن رحم الأم
يرجع لحجمه الطبيعي ولمكانه الطبيعي مع عملية الرضاعة الطبيعية
هذا الالتصاق القريب جدًّا أن يشم ريحة الأم أكثر
طبعًا هو حتى الرضاعة الصناعية تخلي الطفل يشم
بس ما بيكون مثل الملامسة الجسدية للجلد
يعمل وقاية للأم كمان من الاكتئاب ما بعد الولادة
نفسها عملية إدرار الحليب والمص
فلها فوائد كثير جدًّا
فيه مادة دهنية تكون في دماغ الطفل تزيد من ذكاءه
وتتكون من حليب الأم
فوائد جدًّا كبيرة
وأنا أعرف أن مش كل الأمهات، كما نكون واقعيين
بعض الأمهات تجيهم أعراض صحية ما يقدروا يرضعوا
وبعضهم، سبحان الله، حليبهم ما يكون كافي
أو تشعر أن عندي حليب يكفي للطفل
فيجيهم تأنيب ضمير
عشان كذا دائمًا نقول القاعدة
قدمي أفضل ما عندك
حاول أن تسترخي أكثر، تتفرغي
تاكلي الأكل الصحي اللي يدرّ الحليب
والله سويت كله وما قدرت أرضع رضاعة طبيعية
أنتِ قدمتِ اللي عليكِ
طيب الحين نجي لما بعد السنتين
يجي التحدي هو كيف أقدر أبني شخصية الطفل
وهنا كثير من الوالدين والآباء اللي يهتموا لهذا الموضوع
أن أنت تهتم أنك تبنيه، بس عادةً يجي التحدي
فأيش الشكل المثالي لبناء شخصية الطفل؟
أيش هي منها جينيات ومنها سلوكيات يتعلمها؟
أولًا هو ماهو منتج جاهز
كثير من الآباء يعتقد أن المفروض يسمع كلامي، المفروض والمفروض
احنا مرة عندنا لغة عالية في التربية اللي هي المفروض
في الحقيقة أبناءنا عبارة عن مقادير
وعلى مدار الحياة يبدأوا يتكونوا
وهذه المقادير تنبني من خبرات الحياة
أنا مرة أتفاجأ لما أسمع هذه الأسئلة وكثير أسمعها
كيف أخلي ولدي يسمع كلام؟
كيف أخلي ولدي ما يعاندني؟ كيف أتحكم بولدي؟
الحقيقة، الإجابة ولا شيء ما تقدر تسويه من هذا الأشياء كلها
سبحان الله ، من خلال الحياة وتجاربها هم يبدأوا يكوّنوا شخصياتهم
60% من صفاتنا الشخصيات احنا نولد فيها ،وراثية
البيئة الاجتماعية والعاطفية ممكن تثبتها أو ممكن تقللها
ممكن طفلي يتولد عصبي آخذ جينات عمي وللا أبويا
مثلًا الطفل هذا عصبي
بس البيئة الاجتماعية والعاطفية، تواصلي العاطفي معاه والاجتماعي
النمذجة، أنا مين في عصبيتي
ممكن هذه الصفة الموروثة تكون مهذبة
أو تصير موقفة أساسًا
وعندنا مساحة للاكتساب
فبالتالي أنا ما أقدر أقول واحد، اثنان، ثلاثة
كل المطلوب في هذا العمر
أنك تكون شخص متعلم قدر المستطاع
حاول أنك دائمًا تتعلم من أبناءك، من التجارب
وفّر بيئة عاطفية آمنة
بمعنى دائمًا قدّم الحب، وقدّم الرعاية، قدّم هذا التواصل
وأيش ما تصير من سلوكيات حاول دائمًا تتذكر
أنت مسؤول عن الرعاية، منت مسؤول عن التغيير أو التحكم
مثلًا أنا لما يجيني طفل يشتكوا الأهالي
هذا العمر الصغير، أنه عنيد
هو لازم يصير عنيد في الثلاث سنين
الثلاث سنين، سبحان الله، يطلع من مرحلة التمركز حول ذاته
الطفل في أول سنتين يكون متمركز حول ذاته
أنا ومن بعدي الطوفان
يدخل البقالة يشيل الحلاوة ويطلع
على أساس أن هذا كله يملكه وعادي
مو مستوعب أن فيه فلوس لازم تندفع وغيره، وهذا الطبيعي
الثلاثة سنين، سبحان الله، الطفل يبدأ يشعر بالانفصال عن هذا التمركز
يبدأ يستوعب العالم الخارجي أكثر
أن فيه فلوس، أبغى فلوس، أعطيني وغيره
علامة هذا الانفصال عن نفسه، احنا نسميها (عناد)
بس في الحقيقة هو يبغى يجرب
أنا لما أقول لا، أيش بيصير
أنا لما ألبس البلوز الصفراء على الخضراء
هي ماهي ماشية بس أنا أبغى أسويها
لما ماما تقول لي تبغى تأكل، أنا أقول لها لا
بس أبغى أشوف ماما أيش يصير فيها، أو يختبر
هنا تبدأ أشياء كثيرة تنضج في شخصياتهم
إذا لو ما عندي هذه المعلومة كأب وأم؛ بسويه كأنه ند معايا
ما يسمع كلامي، يكسر كلمتي، يعاندني، تعبني
بس في الحقيقة، هذا الجهد اللي أنت حاطه عليك، ترى ماهو كذا
هو يحاول يظهر شخصيته
فبالتالي، احنا عندنا طريقة مرة مريحة، نسميها الإيد المفتوحة
الإيد المفتوحة نبدأها أول شيء
كثير من الثقافات لما ترحب أحد تفتح إيدها
فأول شيء نقول دائمًا رحّب بابنك
رحّب بكل التفاصيل، أبسط شيء لما يصحى الصباح
هل يرحّب فيه؟ حسسه أنه يوم صحي
مو أنه، استغفر الله ولا تسمع، يا ريته ما صحي
خليه نايم، نوم الظالم عبادة
وترى ما ندري أن احنا ممكن نُسقط هذه الأشياء ويحسوا فيها أبناءنا
لكن لما يصحى ونقول له صباح الخير وأهلا وسهلا
ودائمًا أقول له قد أيش وجودك يعني لي في حياتي؟
أنا مرة سعيدة أنك موجود
أحب بسمع صوتك، حكاياتك مرة تبسطني
أيش صار عندك اليوم في المدرسة؟
أنا أحكي له كمان، أيش رأيك اليوم ألبس هذا وللا ذا؟
هذا التواصل والتفاعل يحسّس الطفل إن أنا بهجة في هذه العائلة
وهذا ترى ما تتطلب لا مستوى تعليمي ولا فلوس
ولا نقول مشغولين، مستحيل أكون مشغولة عن صباح الخير
فهذا يبدأ يثبّت الثقة بالنفس عند هذا الطفل
اللبنات الأولى
اليد المفتوحة كمان شكل ثاني لها
أن أنا أعطي مساحة له من التعلم في الحياة
عشان كذا دائمًا نقول للأهل، اتركوا لهم مساحة يمروا بالخبرات
مثلًا لو أحد وسط جمعة العائلة وأخذ لعبته منه
لا تدخل على طول تشيل اللعبة وتعطيه هي
خليه يجرب، خليه يضايق، مو مشكلة
خلينا نشوف أيش يسوي، بيضربه، بيعصّب
خليه يختبر نفسه في هذا الحياة
بس لما يوصل لحد خطير أو يصير فيه خلاص...
تدخّل
هنا ذيك الساعة يدك هذه تمسك الحد. فهذا مهم
الشيء الثاني، مهم لما يمروا بحالات انفعالية وللا عاطفية
أن أنا ما نصلحها، ولكن أكون بالقرب منها
هذا أكثر شيء يخربط الأهل
أن ولدي زعلان كيف أخليه فرحان؟ ولدي خايف كيف أخليه...؟
بالحقيقة أنت ما راح تقدر تغيّر الشعور على طول بضغطة زر
أولًا، أنت اعمل مرآة لهذا الشعور
ولدي خايف؛ خليه يشعر بأمن مع خوفه
هذا اللي ممكن لو فقدها الإنسان بكرة
لما تجي له مشاعر خوف؛ يهلع منها ويرتبك منها
لا بأس أن تغضب، لا بأس أنك تخاف أو ترتبك
هذه المشاعر ماهي خطيرة على الإنسان
وللا ربنا ما كان خلقها فينا
لكن كيف تحس بهذا الشعور وما ترتبك وكيف تفهمه
كيف تحسه فين في جسمك، كيف تعبّر عنه
وبعدين الخطوة رقم ثلاثة، أنا كيف أتصرف مع هذا الشعور
فلو خايف؛ تبغى حضن، تبغانا نخرج من ذا المكان مثلًا
أنت لو غضبان من صاحبك؛ تبغانا نتكلم معاه، تبي تأخذ استراحة منه
تبغى بعد كذا لما تروح جمعة بيت جدتك
ما تاخذ اللعبة عشان لا ياخذها ولد عمك
نبدأ نساعد الطفل أنه يفكر
بس أول خطوة، أن ما تشعر به حقيقي وطبيعي وصحي
الغضب ماهو غلط، والخوف ماهو غلط
متى يكون غضب؟ لما هو يكون المحرك لنا
ومتى يكون محرك؟ لما ما نعطي لهذا الشعور اهتمام
فالشعور بيتفاقم عشان يبغى يقودنا
لكن أنا أقود هذا الشعور
بالنسبة للعناد، كيف الواحد يتعامل معاه؟
أنا أقول له كذا، هو يسوي عكس
أنا أقول له كذا، هو يسوي مدري كيف
يجي يبغى يسوي حاجة غلط
طبعًا مرة ثانية، نترك ساحة مرة واسعة
أن هم يمارسوا العناد
مثلًا لو أنه أصر على شيء، وهذا الشيء ما يعتبر خطير عليه
أو يعتبر لا بأس فيه؛ خلاص أخليه يمارسه
أخليه يشعر بكيف أنا أصنع قرار وأشوفه على أرض الواقع
الشيء الثاني، كلما كانت البيئة منظمة؛ كلما نظمنا العناد
فالطفل لما يعرف أن مو مسموح لي أتفرج أكثر من نص ساعة
بيعنّد ويعنّد، بس عارف أن أعلى حد حقه هو نص ساعة
فهنا نبدأ نعطيهم خيارات
تبغى تشوف النص الساعة قبل الغذاء وللا بعد الغذاء مثلًا؟
فهنا أعطيته مساحة أنه يختار
والطفل لما يختار يصير حليف لاختياره
فهو خلاص عارف أن انا اخترت قبل الغذاء
فيحس أن أنا اللي اخترت
فأشبعنا جزء من شخصيته، نميناها له
العواقب لازم تكون واضحة
وهنا نقول للأهل لا تكثروا كثير من العواقب
الخطوط الحمراء اللي يتعاقب عليها الطفل
ما مفروض تكون قائمة مرة كثيرة
أيش الشيء اللي أنا أحس أن هذا خط أحمر
لازم يكون له عاقبة
ممكن الإيذاء الجسدي بينهم مثلًا أو السب أو الشتم
أشياء بسيطة
خلينا نقول عصّب، وقال أنا ما أحب هذه قوانين البيت
خليه يعترض، خليه يمارس الاعتراض، فين المشكلة؟
بالعكس هذا دليل أن هو يشعر بأمان نفسي واجتماعي
أني أقدر أكون أنا، أُعبّر
ما أخسر حبي لو أنا قلت أنا مو عاجبتني قوانينكم
بس حسب القوانين في الأخير
أيش الأشياء اللي تهز شخصية الطفل؟
اللي تهز شخصية الطفل أولًا هو عدم التواصل معاه
لما الطفل يحس أن مشاعري مو مهمة
وممكن بحسن نية كآباء وأمهات نوصل لهم هذا الشعور
لما يبكي، لا تبكي أنت رجال، عيب تبكي
فبالتالي، يحس أن دموعي غلط، حزني غلط، غضبي غلط
بس هذا مو غلط، أنت إنسان، أنت بتغضب
فهذا أول شيء يهز شخصيته
أن فيه جزء مني غلط لازم أتخلص منه
بس تعرف شيء أنت ما تقدر تتخلص منه، أنت إنسان
هذا أول شيء يبدأ يحسسه أن فيه شيء مني غير مقبول
هذا يبدأ يهز في شخصيته
لما الطفل ما تصير عنده ساحات للتواصل والحوار
كلما كان عندنا ساحات للتواصل والحوار
وقدر الطفل يتكلم ويحكي ويعبر ويتكلم ويشارك
كلما شعر بأن أنا مهم، أنا لي مكان
فيه دراسة جميلة قبل يومين قرأتها
هي صح للمدارس، بس من باب أولى تنطبق في البيت
لقوا أن الأطفال اللي يصير عليهم ترحيب بشكل فردي
يعني المعلم اللي يقول صباح الخير يا نايف
أهلًا وسهلاً يا أحمد، بالاسم بشكل فردي
لقوا أن هذول الأطفال ترتفع نسبة التواجد الأكاديمي
أعلى بـ 20% من الأطفال اللي ما يُرحب فيهم
فيصير الطفل متواجد أكثر أكاديمي
أيش يعني تواجد أكاديمي؟
يعني بعطيك وجه يا معلم، بتواصل معاك
بحل الواجب، بحط جهد فيّ
فأنا لما أعطي هذا الترحيب وهذا الاهتمام الفردي لأولادي
هذا يعطيهم تواجد أكثر في البيت
يشعروا أن هذه ساحة مشتركة بيننا، وهذا يبني الشخصية
دائمًا نقول، يولدوا أبناءنا بصفات، وهذه ما نقدر نغيّر بعضها
بس كيف أنا أقدر أحتويها؟
كثير من الأهل مثلًا يكرهوا بعض الصفات، وهذه صفات أصيلة فيهم
مثلًا خلينا نقول التفصيلي، يفصّل مرة
يفكر بزيادة، وفين بنروح، وفين بنجي، وفين بنسافر
يتنرفزوا من هذا الطبع، هو كذا
فلا تنزعج من هذا الجزء اللي مولود فيه
هذا عشان ما نكسر شخصيته، أن احنا نعرف أن هذا طبعك
أن احنا نقبل هذا الطبع، نحتويه
ليش فيه شخصيات أطفال تكون أقوى من شخصيات أطفال آخرين؟
عوامل مرة كثير، بعضها يكون بالولادة، سبحان الله
بعض الأطفال يولدوا عندهم هذا الظهور الأعلى في شخصياتهم
بعضهم يكونوا اجتماعيين واضحة شخصياتهم
بعضهم يكونوا هادئين، خجولين
وما في واحد فيهم غلط. هذا واحد
اثنين، طفل تكون بيئته العاطفية والاجتماعية
غذّت هذا الظهور في شخصيته
مو بس بالبيت على فكرة
هذه كمان حاجة ثانية مهمة، عبدالرحمن
كثير من الأهل، احنا اليوم أنا مو بس بربي أطفالي
أنا اليوم الإعلام جالس بيربّي معاي. المدرسة، الأصدقاء
فيه بيئات كثير اجتماعية حول الطفل
كلما يكبروا أبناءنا؛ كلما تتوسع هذه البيئات أكثر
فلا نعتقد أن أنا أقدر أتحكم 100% في هذا البناء
ترى فيه عوامل ثانية تتحكم فيهم
ودائمًا نقول أنا مسؤولة عن ما أقدم، ماني مسؤولة عن النتيجة
لو تجي تقرأ القرآن، نماذج الوالدية كلها في القرآن
النسبة الأغلب تقول لك أن النتيجة ما كانت بيدهم
نبي الله نوح، ولده ما آمن ولا ركب معاه السفينة
يعقوب عليه السلام
دائمًا أقول، سبحان الله، لو احنا قاعدين في مجموعة الدعم الوالدية
ولو نبي الله نوح مثلًا جالس في جلسة الدعم الوالدية هذه
بيكون عنده نموذج لابن ما سمع كلامه
ما مشي على منظومته القيمية
وأنا كثير أشوف بالعيادة عندي
آباء من أجمل ما يكون منظومتهم القيمية والتربوية
سبحان الله، يبتليهم الله ابن مدمن للمخدرات مثلًا
أو ابن راح في صحبة سيئة أو صارت عنده سلوكيات فيها جنوح مثلًا
ففي الأخير نرجع نتذكر بشريتنا
أنا بقدم أفضل ما عندي، بس النتيجة مش 100% نتيجتي أنا
فهذا اللي يسبب الاختلافات
أن فيه أشياء كثير حول الطفل ممكن تأثر
أيش أثر لما تعطي الطفل لك مسؤوليات أكبر من عمره؟
بغرض أنك تخليه يعتمد لنفسه، أن يكون أقوى
هذا يرجع على حسب الثقافة
أنا أذكر مرة كنا بأمريكا، فكنا مجموعة من الطلبة في فترة الدكتوراة
وكنا من أربع جنسيات مختلفة
فمعنا واحد من دولة إفريقية وأنا كنت عربية
وواحد كان أوروبي وأمريكي
كان مرة مضحك متى أول واحد فينا مسك السكين
اللي من دولة إفريقية من عمره سنتين هو يطلع يصيد الأسود
أنا مثلًا مسكت السكين على عمر عشر سنين
الأمريكي ما مسكتها إلا على عمر المراهقة
المسؤولية تختلف حسب التركيبة الاجتماعي الثقافية
وهذا لازم نقدّرها يا عبدالرحمن
احنا حتى كمجتمع هنا مثلًا عربي أو سعودي أو غيره
ترى المناطق الجغرافية تفرق في المسؤوليات
المسؤولية مثلًا اللي في منطقة معينة ممكن تختلف
لكن لو قلنا أن هذه المسؤولية في عرفي الاجتماعي والثقافي
أعلى من الطفل؛ هذه ممكن تربك الطفل
لأن الطفل لما تكون هذه إمكانياتي
وأنت تعطيني مسؤولية أكبر من إمكانياتي
تربكه ممكن، تجهده
ممكن تحسسه أن فيه شيء غلط في
أنا غلط، أنا ليه ماني قادر أضبطها؟
هذه المسؤولية مرة أكبر مني
فبالتالي، يبدأ يحس أن أنا غلط
أنا فيّ شيء غلط، أو أنا ماني جيد بما يكفي
أو أنا ماني مسؤول
بينما الواقع أنت أُعطيت شيء أثقل منك، أثقل من إمكانياتك
فلذلك الموازنة ضروري جدًّا
أثر البيئة نفسها، بس برضه هنا علاقة الأب والأم ببعض أو تصرفاتهم
على الطفل، كيف الواحد يحكمها؟ كيف أثرها على الطفل؟
قصدك علاقتهم كزوجين، وأثرها؟
أيوة، طبعًا هي مرة لها ...
لما يعصبوا، لما يضايقوا، لما ينفعلوا
لها أثر كبير جدًّا
دائمًا فيه كثير يقولوا مثلًا أنا كزوجة تعيسة
بس هذا شيء وتربيتي لأبنائي شيء آخر
في الحقيقة، هذا الشيء اللي كثير من الأهل ما يعرفوه
أن كلما كان الطفل أصغر؛ كلما كان أكثر شفافية
تجاه مشاعر الأم والأب، قادر على استيعابها
نرجع مرة ثانية لنفس التجربة الوجه الجامد
مجرد جمود وجه الأم، حس فيه هذا اللي عمره شهور
وصار حاسس أن فيه شيء غلط في ماما
ولازم أسوّي شيء عشان أساعدها فيّ
أو أبويا كيف أساعده
فبالتالي، بشكل مجمل وبشكل تفصيلي
بشكل مجمل عافيتي النفسية كأم أو كأب
هي لها تأثير مباشر، مش بس على شخصية الطفل
حتى على وضعه الأكاديمي، صداقاته، حياته الاجتماعية، بشكل مباشر
علاقتنا الزوجية، توافقها أو اختلافها يأثر بشكل مباشر
الطفل مثلًا لما دائمًا يشوف فيه خلاف بين أبويا وأمي
فيه صياح، فيه عصبية، أيش يحس؟
الطفل في أول خمسة سنوات، كيف يستقبل هذا الاختلاف؟
يحسب أن أنا السبب
أنا لما عملت مع ضحايا الحروب لفترة طويلة
يعتقدوا أنه هم السبب في الحرب، تخيل!
فالطفل لأنه يحس أن فيه شيء غلط
وهو متمركز حول نفسه؛ فيحس أن أنا سويت شيء غلط
يمكن أنا السبب
فتخيل هذا الجهد الكبير
بابا وماما يتضاربوا يمكن عشاني
ماما زعلانة، يمكن عشاني أنا
فهذا جهد الثقيل جدًّا على أي طفل أن هو يتحمله
لما يكبر الطفل ويبدأ يشوف الخلافات
هنا شعور الأمان النفسي يبدأ يتأثر
خاصة لو كانت هذه العلاقة أخذت لمنحى العنف
أنه ممكن ماما اليوم تنضرب، ممكن ماما اليوم تتسب أو تنهان
من الدراسات المؤلمة كانت أن الطفل يتأثر أكثر
لما يشوف العنف على الأم من لو تمارس العنف عليه
لو الطفل انضرب من الأب؛ يترك أثر نفسي سيء
لكن لو شاف أمه اللي بتنضرب؛ يترك أثر نفسي أشد من أثره نفسي عليه
لأنه يشعر بالعجز
وبعدين شخص يفترض أن هو يكون مصدر أمان لي
فاقد الأمان في جسده وفي عواطفه وفي كرامته
فيدمر حقيقي، العنف اللي يصير بين الزوجين
سواء عنف جسدي أو عنف لفظي أو حتى عاطفي
لما الطفل يدخل البيت ويلاقي الأب ما يطالع في الأم
الأم ما تطالع فيه، بالأيام ما يتكلموا
باين بينهم أن ما في مشاعر ألفة، باين كل واحد في عالم
يربك الطفل، يحسسه أن ما في أمان، هم ماهم سعيدين
من الدراسات مؤخرًا اللي عملتها وأنا تفاجأت جدًّا بنتيجتها
فيه عندنا مقياس عالمي معروف اسمه خبرات الطفولة الضارة
ففيه عشر خبرات إذا عاشها الطفل في طفولته
تؤثر بشكل كبير على صحته الجسدية والنفسية
أنا عملتها مع مدمنين الإباحية
الناس اللي عندهم إدمان للإباحية
إدمان الإباحية كثير من الناس تعتقد
أن هي عبارة عن شهوة جنسية مفرطة بيشبعها بالإباحية
المسألة ماهي كذا تمامًا، مالها دخل أبدًا
هي عبارة عن جراح قديمة جدًّا، أو مشاعر أو آلام نفسية
يبغى يخدّرها بأي متعة يدمن عليها
يقدر يدمن لألعاب الفيديو، أو للإباحيات أو للكوكايين أو شرب
أيش ما تكون نمط إدماني يرفعه عنده
هذه الخبرات الضارة بختصر لك هي
عنف جنسي يقع الطفل أو إساءة جنسية
عنف لفظي أو اجتماعي أو جسدي
أو ابعاد، يُبعد الأهل منه
ينسجن الأب أو الأم تتطلق تختفي أو غيره
أو ضعف العافية النفسية عند الوالدين في طفولته
تعرف أيش من هذه الخبرات كلها هي رقم واحد عن مدمنين الإباحية؟
ضعف العافية النفسية لآبائهم
وهذه أيش تعريفها؟
اللي هو لما الأب يكون مهترئ نفسيًّا
لما الأم تكون تعبانة ومجهدة نفسيًّا
في حياة هذا الطفل في طفولته
تخيل أثرها البعيد
احنا نشوفه بعيد أدمن
بس خلال هذه السنوات أمي مهترئة في عافيتها النفسية
يأثر على عافيتي أنا النفسية
بالتالي هي ما عرفت كيف تعتني بعافيتها النفسية
أنا كمان مع هذه النمذجة، ما أعرف كيف أعتني بعافيتي النفسية، فبالتالي...
أنا تخيلت وافتراضي في هذه الدراسة
أن اللي تعرض للإساءة الجنسية هو اللي بيدمن على هذا
تخيل الإساءة جنسية طلع ما لها دخل في إدمان الإباحية
ما هي من الخبرات الأعلى
أعلى خبرة كانت هي صحة الوالدين النفسية
فلا نعتقد أن شيء بيني وبين أمهم، ما لهم دخل الصغار
لا، له دخل
كيف يتعاملوا الآباء مع هذه المسألة والأمهات؟
الزعل جزء من الحياة، المشاكل جزء من الحياة، تصير
طبعًا
فكيف يتعاملوا في وجود طفلهم؟
أولًا، نبدأ من البداية الحوار والحوار والحوار
مساحة التواصل لازم تكون متواجدة دائمًا
أصعب شيء يا عبدالرحمن، لما الزوجين ما تكون عندهم ساحة للتواصل
كل واحد ماشي في الحياة بسرعة، ما في تواصل
والتواصل بكل أشكاله الجسدي والعاطفي والاجتماعي واللفظي
فلما ما يصير فيه تواصل، بالتالي المشاكل ما بيكون لها ساحة
نقدر نستبصرها، ونحكي عنها
لما ما تكون فيه هذه الساحة، فين بتروح هذه المشاكل؟
تضرب في عافيتنا النفسية وعافيتنا الجسدية
كثير من الناس تعاني من آلام جسدية، صداع مزمن
آلام في الظهر، في العظام
وترى أن أجسادهم ما فيها مشاكل
بس عافيتهم النفسية اهترئت؛ فاهترئت الأجساد
فيه كتاب جميل للدكتور «قابور ماتي» اسمه
«عندما يقول الجسم لا» (When the Body Says No)
لما جسمك يقول لا، خلاص كفاية
يفضل، ما عندك ساحة
فالزوجين لو فقدوا ساحة التواصل
فبالتالي هنا المشاكل تبدأ تأثر في عافيتهم النفسية
الخلاف طبيعي بين الزوجين، المشاكل طبيعية
الآلام اللي يسببوها لبعضهم أيضًا طبيعية
أنا ممكن أسبب إحباط وممكن يخذل، هذا كله طبيعي
مو طبيعي أن تكون العلاقة مثالية خالية من المشاكل
اللي مو طبيعي أن ما تكون عندنا ساحة جيدة للتواصل
ولإدارة هذه الخلافات أو للحديث عنها
فلما تفقد هذه الساحة؛ تأثر المشاكل
بس وجودها بشكل طبيعي ما يؤثر على الطفل
لا. خلينا ناخذ مثال
لو هذا الطفل يعرف أن بابا وماما الآن اختلفوا على موضوع
نبرة صوتهم متزنة، حوارهم مع بعض
فيه اختيار جيد للعبارات، فيه حفظ للكرامة
فيه حفظ للود بينهم، فيه احترام في هذا التواصل
بيتجادلوا، ولكن بيكون هذا الجدال حافظ لكرامتهم
فيه مساحة جيدة للأخذ والعطاء
أنا أشوف أبويا يسمع لأمي بالكامل
بعدين يبدأ يأخذ ويعطي معاها
هذا هو أفضل نموذج تقدمه
من النماذج اللي نخاف منها لما يكون الأب والأم
طول الوقت سعيدين قدام أبناءهم
أيش يصير؟
لأن في الحقيقة أنت ما تقدر تكون سعيدة 24 ساعة
الإنسان يمر بكل صعود وهبوط
لكن لما أنا بس أبيّن الصورة المثالية هذه
هذا الطفل بكرة لو كبر وتزوج
وصار بينه خلافات مع زوجته
وحس بحزن أو بغضب؛ بيحس فيه شيء غلط
أبوي وأمي كانوا دائمًا سعيدين، كذا المفروض نكون
هذه هي الصورة صح
بس في الحقيقة أبوي وأمي عطوني
صورة وحدة من صورة الحياة كلها
لذلك دائمًا نقول للأهل كون إنسان قدام ابنك
مارس الاختلاف عادي
ولكن مارسه وأنت تحفظ كرامتك وكرامة الطرف الآخر
بل بالعكس هذا بيعلمهم كيف نتعامل مع الاختلاف
أنتِ قلتِ الحياة صارت سريعة، الأشياء صارت سريعة
بس وحدة من الأشياء برضه اللي أتوقع أنها تأثر على حياة الناس
وخصوصًا في التربية اللي هو وجود التقنية
وهذا اللي يصير
صعب مرة أنك تتكلم وأنت بعيد عن التجربة
بس عشان كذا أنا بسألك
اللي هو لما الطفل يبكي بعطيه الجوال؛ بيسكت تمامًا
ويسكت ساعتين أو خمس ساعات، خلاص أنا أنساه وأقدر أروّق
فمتى أعطيه جوال؟ متى ما أعطيه جوال؟ أو آيباد؟
متى تعطيه جهاز وهو يتصفح ويفكني من شره؟
جمعية الطب الأمريكية للأطفال، وجمعيات كثير
التوصيات أن أول سنتين في عمر الطفل
الإنسان ما يتعرض نهائيًّا للشاشات
نهائيًّا ما يتعرض لها
لو نقول الدماغ 80% - 90% ينمو
فهو بحاجة إلى خبرات طبيعية وحقيقية
فالشاشة ما تعطي هذه الخبرة أبدًا
فلما نشوف أحد يضحك، الطفل يحتاج أحد يضحك له، وهو يضحك
خبرة ذاتية
اللي في التلفزيون بيبقى يضحك طول الوقت مثلًا أو يتحرك
ما يقدر يكون فيه تواصل مباشر بينه وبينه
الشيء الثاني، أساسًا رؤية الشاشات
الطفل يحتاج يشوف الشيء بكل الأبعاد
الشاشة ما تعطي له
فمناطق الإبصار تتأثر
نفس الموجات اللي تصير وغيرها
هذه كلها ماهي صحية على نمو دماغه
فيفترض الطفل تمامًا ما يتعرّض لها
للأسف اليوم الإلكترونيات صارت تشعرنا كآباء وأمهات
أنها أسهل وأسرع طريقة أن أنا أسكّته
طيب سؤال ليش أصلًا نبغاه يسكت؟
طيب عادي خليه يزن
مرة ثانية، هي قوة التحمل فينا
فيه كثير من الناس يحسبوا أن الطفل لما يناغي أو يزن
معناته أن فيه شيء غلط، هو ما في شيء غلط
هو بس منزعج، وخلوه ينزعج، فين المشكلة؟
يصير عندنا هذه القابلية أنه يعيش هذا الشعور
فهو الآن منزعج، ضغطنا زر على طول حطيناه شتتناه
شوف تفرج هذا الشيء
يبغى يبكي؛ حطيناه قدام هذا الشيء
فأيش يصير عند الإنسان؟
نحن نختزل مشاعره، نختزل أن هو يختبرها أو يعيشها
ومرة ثانية، تراها ثقافة مجتمع
أنا أقول لك قبل كم شهر كنت في اليابان وانصدمت
تخيل كل مطعم ندخله فيه أطفال
ولا طفل على الجهاز، وما في لهم أصوات وما هم مزعجين
وكل مرة كنت أقول هذه العائلة غريبة وهذه غريبة
بعدين طلع المجتمع كله، احنا الغريبين
كل طفل كان يجلس، ثقافة المجتمع هناك أنهم ما يتعرضوا للأجهزة
ثقافة المجتمع هناك لو تلاحظ أن الطفل يتفاعل مع الكل اللي موجود
هذا المشهد شفته متكرر
الكبار يتكلموا، الأطفال معاهم يتكلموا
فيه كذا طفل شفته عادي عمره ثلاث سنين
قاعد يلعب بس بالشوكة طول الوقت
احنا ايش سوينا في أولادنا؟
ما أعطيناهم مساحة يمسكوا الشوكة ويلعبوا فيها
لا، خلاص خذ الجهاز
فتلاقينا أول ما ندخل للمطعم، ممكن قبل ما أحط شنطتي
أول شيء أحط الجهاز وأحط الطفل
فاحنا اللي خلقنا هذه الآلية في تهدئتهم
تبغاني أهدّيك؛ أحط لك هذا الجهاز
بينما في مجتمعات لليوم عايشة
في اليابان ماهو خيار لأطفالهم
بالتالي، صارت الملعقة والشوكة والأشياء هذه البسيطة
أعطتهم مساحة أنهم هم يلعبوا فيها أو يتشتتوا مثلًا أو غيره
أنا دائمًا أقول ما هم أطفالنا
احنا الطفل مولود واحنا اللي نقرر
فهذه ثقافة والدية
أنت تقولين السنتين الأولى، خطر وجود الجهاز معها
بعدها أعطيه الجهاز؟
يفترض أن الطفل ما يتعرض أصلًا لأجهزة لوحية
يفترض تقريبًا في أول عشرة سنين
عشرة سنين؟
عشرة سنين، المفروض شاشة كبيرة تكون، ولها وقت محدد
وحاجة ثانية، افتح شيء يكون أدنى حد عشرين دقيقة مكتمل، ليش؟
عشان الخبرات العقلية اللي تصير للطفل
هو لما يشوف شيء، فيه أكثر من عملية عقلية
تشتغل في نفس الوقت، التركيز، الاهتمام، التحليل، التوقع
مثلًا، أيش بيصير بعد هذا الحدث؟
تذكر يوم كنا نتفرج «توم وجيري»؟
ما أعرف إذا أنت كنت من جيل الديناصورات مثلي وللا لا
لما كان «جيري» يروح، عارفين أنه لو خرج بيجي له «توم»
فهذه كلها عمليات تحليل، توقع وغيره
أنا لما أعطي جهاز صغير للطفل، أيش يصير؟
كل هذه العمليات؛ هذا الجهاز ما بيسمح له فيها، ليه؟
لأن أيش يصير عند الطفل؟
هذه اللي صاروا يسمونها الآن «التمرير»
أن أنا بفضل بس باصباعي
لو تشوف الأطفال كيف، بس باصباعه
ومعاد صار عندهم مدة التحمل أو التركيز
كل ما لها عند البشر بدأت تنقص، ليش؟
لأن أنا عندي خيار أن أنا بسرعة أطلّع، ما بتحمل
فتخيل هذا الطفل الصغير لما ما يتحمل وما يبي يستنى
فبالتالي، كثير من العمليات العقلية اللي ممكن نستفيد منها
لو شاف شيء في شاشة ولعشرين دقيقة؛ راحت منه
وأن أنا بطير
فبالتالي هذا الجهاز اللوحي؛ بيشتته ويقلل تركيزه أكثر
يعطيه انطباع وهذا لليوم احنا ندفع ثمنه
أن كل شيء أقدر أغيّره بضغطة زر بأصبعي
أنا مثلًا أبغى دحين تشتروا لي شيء، هيا دحين، هيا دحين
ما عاد قادر يستوعب أن احنا لازم نركب سيارة أو نروح أو غيره
الحين أطلبيه من جوالك
شعور الطفل أن كل شيء يصير بضغطة زر
وبالتالي شعور الإحباط بيصير متفاقم عندهم
لأن الحياة ماهي بضغطة زر
وكلما يكبر في الحياة؛ يلاقي أن العلاقات ماهي بضغطة زر
النجاح مش بضغطة زر، الدراسة ماهي بضغطة زر
فهنا يبدأ يصير، أنا تعودت أن كل شيء أسويه بأصباعي كذا
أنتِ تشوفين مثلًا هنا أن التيك توك خطير جدًّا؟
طبعًا. الشيء الثاني يا عبدالرحمن
الدراسات تقول أن طفل من كل ثلاث أطفال
يتعرض لمحتوى إباحي قبل سبع سنوات
أنا صارت معاي شخصيًّا
بنتي كانت صغيرة عمرها أربع سنين
كان عندي في الآيباد تبقى تنزل لعبة رسم
فهي عمرها خمس سنين، واللعبة كانت أكبر من ثلاثة
فآمنة، وتلوين ترى
فأنا بحملها، وسبحان اللي خلاني
تعرف دائمًا احنا على بال ما يتحمل
ممكن أقول لي داحين يتحمل؛ واشتغلي ولوني
بس مسكته واللعبة بتحمل؛ راح التحميل
وجاء مشهد إباحي كامل، ومو كرتون، مو شيء
وما في أي زر أضغط عشان أقفله
فإجباري بتفرج عليه
كمية الروعة اللي صابتني
لو لثواني أنا أعطيت اللوح وبنتي جنبي
تنتهك ويساء لها جنسيًّا بهذا المشهد الإباحي
طبعًا من بعدها صار عندي رعب
ما في لعبة تتحمل، ما في شيء، نبغى نلوّن نلون على...
لأنه ما تضمين
أيش الأثر اللي بتحصل على الطفل من مشاهدته؟
إرباك، لأن أيش هذا المشهد؟
أنا ما أعرف أيش بيصير
ليش بدون ملابس؟ أيش قاعد يصير؟
ممكن يفسرها تفسيرات حسب خياله
هذا مثلًا ضرب أو هذه أذية أو غيره
ممكن يثير عنده الفضول ويبدأ يبحث
وكثير من مدمنين الإباحية اللي مروا عليّ؛ بدأ معاهم فضول
أن أنا شفت مشهد، بعدين أبغى أعرف أكثر
أنت متخيل 291 موقع إباحي ينشأ على شبكة الإنترنت يوميًّا
فالعالم الافتراضي هذا مليان
مليان، على ما أعتقد الظاهر أن ثلث المحتوى اللي في الإنترنت إباحي
فهو عالم غير آمن تمامًا
فدائمًا أقول ليش نغامر ونحط أبناءنا عليه؟
طيب إذا تيك توك واضح بالنسبة لك
أنه على طول بيغيّر، كل شيء يكون بضغطة زر
قدرته في تحمل الأشياء تصير ضعيفة
طيب لو أعطيت يوتيوب أو نتفلكس للأطفال؟
النتفلكس يمكن شوية يختلف
هذه التطبيقات اللي هي فيها...
هذه أولًا تعطيهم حلقات
لو تلاحظ برامج للأطفال اللي تكون جيدة تلاقيها 20 دقيقة عادةً
وهذا هو مدى الاهتمام للطفل
في 20 دقيقة؟
20 دقيقة تمام كافية، ويفترض خلصنا انتهينا ونقفله
ليه ما يشوف الحلقة اللي بعدها
لأن أنت تبدأ تقلص عليه فرص تعلم أخرى
أول شيء نقوله للآباء والأمهات خلوهم يطفشوا
كثير من الأهل يقولوا طفشانين، أيش نسوي فيهم؟
لا تسوي فيهم شيء
مو أنا لما أعطيه الجوال لأنه يزعجني
أنا ما أبغاه يبكي، أنا يزعجني صوت البكاء
فأنتِ تقولي خليه يبكي!
لا ما أبغاه يبكي، أبغاه يسكت
نرجع مرة ثانية، طيب هو ليه يزعجك؟ هو بيبكي
بس إذا الجوال أدى المفعول، سكّته، مو حلو؟
لأن على المدى الطويل أنت بتعرضه لعالم غير آمن، هذا واحد
اثنين، كثير دراسات صارت، ارتبط الإبداع بوقت الفراغ و( الطفش)
فيه دراسة صارت حطوا مجموعتين: عشرين، عشرين شخص
وأعطوهم كاسات بلاستيك
قالوا لهم طلعوا أشكال مبدعة
مجموعة حطوا جوالاتهم معاهم
المجموعة الثانية سحبوا الجوالات
هذولا أربعة دقائق سووا شكل وقعدوا على جوالاتهم
هذولا جلسوا ساعتين وأبدعوا وطلعوا، لأن ما عندهم خيار غيره
أنا تجربتي الشخصية نفس الشيء على أطفالي
لما تجي إجازة الصيف، خلاص ما عندكم غير
هذه الـ 20 دقيقة اللي تتفرجوا فيها
أنتِ تعطيهم 20 دقيقة في اليوم؟
20 دقيقة على التلفزيون
في اليوم؟
في اليوم. يطفشوا؟ يطفشوا
مع الجوال؟
لا طبعًا
آيباد؟
لا
جوالك ما تعطيهم؟
لا، طبعًا. ولا يعرفوا كلمة المرور
واو!
بس أيش اللي يصير؟
خليني أقولك السيناريو ماهو مثالي
يتحلطموا ويزعلوا، ما أعرف إذا بيشوفوا هذا الشيء بيزعلوا مني
ويتضايقوا وأيش نسوي؟
لكن أذكّر نفسي أنهم بكرة راح يشكروني
لأنهم يحتاجون هذه المساحة
تعرف أيش يصير يا عبدالرحمن؟
بيخلصوا مرحلة الحلطمة والاعتراض
والله حقيقي، بعدها يروحوا على مرحلة جميلة جدًّا
كل شيء في الحياة تتخيل ويسووه
يطبخوا، يرسموا، ويقلبوا دواليبهم
ويرتبون أشياء صدقة يحسوا ما نحتاجها، يطلعوا أشياء
ويبدأوا يشغلوا نفسهم
وهذا رسالة، مهم نعرف أني ماني مسؤولة
عن تعبئة فراغ وقت ولدي مية بالمية 100%
هذه ماهي مهمتي
طفشانين؟ طيب، أنتوا اللي طفشانين، تصرفوا
أنا لما أنا أطفش ما أجي أقول لكم أنا طفشانة
أنا أتصرف، أروح أدبر نفسي
فيتعلم الطفل، احنا نسميها الانضباط الذاتي
اللي هي تهذيب النفس وتنظيم النفس
أنا كيف أرتب نفسي
فإذا ما أعطيناهم هذه المساحة
ما راح يعرفوا يكتشفوا نفسهم ولا هواياتهم ولا أيش يحبوا
سلبنا أطفالنا الكثير بسبب هذه الأجهزة
فمفترض إلى عشر سنين ما يأخذوا؟
يفترض أنهم ما يتعرضوا لهذه التطبيقات
كثير دراسات صارت مثلًا على سناب شات
السيلفي مثلًا، لقوا أن المراهقين ياخذوا من 42 -65 صورة في اليوم
والشيء الثاني، لاحظوا أنه نسبة الرضا عن أشكالهم
بتضعف مرة كلما أخذوا سيلفي
لأنه يصير مرة فيه تركيز، والفلتر يعطيني خيار
أني أقدر أكون مثل ما أكون
حواجبي مو عاجبتني؛ أغيّرها، فمي مو عاجبني؛ أغيّره
أعطيناهم إمكانية مزيفة
فبالتالي لما أخلص الفلاتر هذه كلها
والاعجابات هذه بسرعة، ونظام المكافأة اللي يصير في الدماغ
وأطالع في وجهي في المراية مش بنفس الحواجب اللي في هذا
الصورة الذاتية تبدأ تتراجع، والثقة تتراجع
فدراسات كثير صارت أن كلما جلسوا على هذه المواقع
كلما انخفض تقديرهم لذواتهم أكثر
لأنه يبدأ يصير عندي إذا حصلت على اعجابات كثيرة؛ معناته أنا جيد
فشعوري أن أنا جيد؛ بيجي من اعجابات وتعليقات
وبينما هذا مو هي المكافأة الحقيقية للإنسان
بالنسبة للبلاي ستيشن، متى الواحد يخلي طفله يلعب؟
بحكم أني بعتقد الحين أنه يختلف تمامًا عن أنه يتفرج مقاطع
هنا يشغل مخه، يبدأ يتفاعل معه
أحس أنه جالس يحرك دماغه
صح. وفيه دراسات كمان صارت أن الجراحين الشطار
لقوا أن من أحد صفاتهم كانوا يلعبوا بالبلاي ستيشن
لأنه يعطيك سرعة بديهة متى تعمل
بالذات الجراحين اللي يعملوا الجراحات بالأجهزة عن بُعد
فهي ماهي شر محض مثلًا
لكن دائمًا نقول بعد سبع سنوات، ليش؟
لأن العضلات الدقيقة في يد الطفل
ما تكتمل إلا بعد سبع سنوات
عشان كذا تشوف خطهم كبير ولما يمسكوا هذا
لأنه ما يكتمل نموه، يحتاج إلى أن يلون ويرسم ويعجن
الين تكتمل
لما أمسكّه وهو صغير وللا...
حتى لو تلاحظ الطفل في أول ستة سنوات ممكن يتأتئ
لأن سرعة العمليات العقلية عنده لسه مش متزنة
يفكر بسرعة ويتكلم أبطأ، فيتأتئ أو غيره
فنقول أول سبع سنين يفضّل أن هو ما يتعرض
لكن لو يبغى يلعب بعدين فيها
الكم مهم، كم عدد الساعات، لو أخذت ساعات معقولة
نص ساعة، مثلًا ساعة متقطعة فيها استراحة
احنا نفسنا الكبار، هذه اللي يسموها عشرين عشرين
أن أنت بعد 20 دقيقة من الشاشة تغمض عينك 20 ثانية
تطالع على مسافة 20 متر، عشان الابصار ما يتأثر
لو هذه التقنيات موجودة عند أبناءنا
فيكون عندهم تعامل ذكي مع هذه الشاشات
أني أحتاج أغمض عيني، ما أطالع وقت طويل
فيه شغلات كانت موجودة زمان والحين اختفت
يمكنها كانت مضرة زمان ومفترض أنها اختفت الحين
أو العكس ما أعرف، اللي هو أنه يطلع من البيت
اليوم الطفل يولد يطلع من البيت غير المدرسة، ما يطلع أبد أصلًا
يمكن يجي عمره ثمانية عشر سنة وما عمره راح إلا أماكن معينة
الحارة والحي، صلته فيها تمامًا منقطعة
بينما أول كانت موجودة
بس أول أنت تخليه مع أولاد الحارة اللي ما تعرفهم
مع مخاطر أنت ما تعرفها، ممكن ينسرق
فدائمًا الأهل يحمونهم بإبقائهم داخل المنزل
أو اخراجهم في أماكن معروفة وين بالضبط يكونون
كيف صارت اليوم؟ هل هي مهمة فعلًا أنه يطلع؟
هو صحيح، شوف كل الزمنين لها مميزاتها ولها مضارها
أولًا كانت الميزة أن مهاراتهم الاجتماعية أعلى
مهارة التفاوض، يطلع الحارة يدبروا الكرة ويدبروا الملعب
فكان عندهم مهارات أعلى
يتضاربوا مع الكبار وغيره
ففيه مهارات كثير اجتماعية
دراسات كثير حتى صارت، واحدة منها كتاب رائع
هو كان لدراسة استمرت سبعة سنين
«طفولة غير متكافئة» (Unequal Childhood)
فالباحثة درست العوائل الفقيرة
اللي آباؤهم في الشغل والأولاد في الحارة
والعوائل اللي هم يرجعوا من المدرسة
يروح نادي كراتيه، بعدين تنس. منظم جدوله
فلقوا أن هذول لما كبروا وعندهم مهارات اجتماعية
في التفاوض وإثبات الذات أعلى مرة بكثير
وما يهلعوا من الفراغ في الوقت أو في الحياة الاجتماعية
بينما هذول لا، كانوا أكثر تنظيم، خلاص جدولي تعبئ لي
فهنا فيه مميزات، وهنا فيه مميزات
الميزة الي فقدناها اليوم فعلًا فيه كثير من التجارب الاجتماعية
سُلبت من أبناءنا وصارت ضئيلة
محدودة بس في بيت العائلة أو بيت الجد أو في المدرسة
ما عاد صار فيه هذه البيئة الاجتماعية
وفي نفس الوقت، برضه ما كان هذيك الصورة مثالية 100%
لأن كثير قصص اليوم مثلًا أشوفها بالعيادة عندي
يكون بالأربعين والخمسين تعرض لتحرشات جنسية لما كان في الحارة
تعرض لايذاءات، تعرض لغيره، لأن كانت الدنيا مفتوحة
ما كان فيه رقابة مرة
اللي نقدر نوازن فيه اليوم، قدر المستطاع
وهذا العبء اللي اليوم علينا كآباء
ما كان موجود في الأجيال اللي قبل
أن أنا كيف أوفر له ساحات اجتماعية صحية؟
فبالتالي، مثلًا ممكن ما عندي غير البيت والمدرسة
بس كيف ممكن أشركه في نادي حق رياضة
مثلًا في وسط الأسبوع أو نهاية الأسبوع
يحب ركوب الخيل، يحب تنس. أحاول أسوي هذه المجموعات
اللي هي خارج إطار المدرسة وخارج إطار العائلة بقدر المستطاع
طبعًا هذه ترمي علينا ثقل وجهد
من زمان أباءنا والأجداد كان هو ياخذ قيلولة العصرية
وأولاده خلاص أتوفر لهم مجانًا، لا أشيله بسيارة أو أوديه
بس نرجع نقول كل زمن يتغير. متطلباته تتغير، تحدياته تتغير
نواكب بقدر المستطاع. نسدد ونقارب
رغم أني أحسن أن الآن أكثر أمانًا من أول
أيوة
بس مع ذلك الأطفال ما يطلعوا برّا البيت نهائيًّا
فعلًا، ما أبغى أقول للأسف
بس هذا الشكل الاجتماعي أو الساحة الاجتماعية
ما عاد صارت موجودة مثل أول
لأن كل ما طلعته توديه مثلًا ركوب الخيل أو طلعته مدري وين
أنت في الأخير عارف وين توديه
صحيح
فتحدي. الآن كيف ممكن أتغلّب عليه؟
هل أخليه يتعرف على أصدقاء؟ هل أنا أختار له أصدقاء؟
أيش الأشياء اللي أقدر أسويها عشان أعطيه هذا البُعد الجديد من الحياة؟
نسدد ونقارب
أول شيء، أنت تعطي الأساسيات في اختيار الأصدقاء
لما أنت تبني العلاقة العاطفية الآمنة
بينك وبينه من عمر صغير؛ أنت حطيت أمان نفسي له
الأمان النفسي يعكس في الأمان في الاختيار
فالطفل بوصلته بتكون آمنة من جوّا
يعرف أيش العلاقة الآمنة والعلاقة المؤذية
لأن هو اختبر وعاش في بيئة آمنة عاطفيًّا واجتماعيًّا
يعرف أيش المؤذي وللا لا
فبالتالي أنا لما أعطيه، لما أتحاور وأتواصل معه
لما أنا وأبوه نختلف واختلافنا يكون صحي وراقي
وكيف نتجادل ونتفاوض، ويصير التنازلات
هذه كلها احنا نسميها لبنات أساسية
وخلينا نقول الأساس اللي يخرج الطفل للعالم الخارجي محمل به
فدائمًا نقول ما أحتاج اشتغل كثير على صداقاته
احتاج اشتغل على ما قبل الصداقات
لما يخرج للمدرسة ويبدأ يختار صداقات
ما المفروض نتحكم 100% في الصداقات
خليه يجرب، خليه يجرب يختار بعض الصداقات
متى أتدخل؟ لما فعلًا أحس فيه خطر محتّم على ولدي
مثل؟
لما مثلًا أعرف أن هذا الولد مدمن للمخدرات
أو مثلًا بيدخن في عمر مرة مبكر
وولدي ممكن من باب أن أنا أنخلط معاك
بتنازل عن هذه القيمة اللي تربيت عليها فباخذ معاك
وأجرب مثلًا التدخين أو غيره من عمر صغير
هنا ممكن يكون
مرة ثانية، نرجع إلى منهجية الإيد المفتوحة
أنا إيدي كذا، أترك له ساحة فيها
بس لو وصل إلى الحد الخطير؛ بوقفه وبحط حد
ممكن يمروا في أثناء الصداقات، وهذا اللي دائمًا يصير
كثير من الأهل يصير عندهم حماية مفرطة على ذا الموضوع
ما أبغى أسميها تنمر، بل ممكن أصدقاءه عيّشوه مواقف
مزعجة أو مؤلمة أو بايخة
ما المفروض أحمي ولا أتدخل
أخليه يجرب هذا الألم
أخليه يجرب لما صاحبه مثلًا يتكلم من وراء ظهره وانزعج
والله ما بروح على قروب الأمهات، مين ولادها تكلم؟
وللا أروح على المدرسة أتضارب
أتركوا المساحة لأبناءكم ينموا اجتماعيًّا، خليهم يختبروا نفسهم
أولًا أخليهم يتألموا، لكن أكون على مسافة الصفر من ألمه
أكون قريبة من ألمه
ابني ما يحتاج مني أغيّر عواطفه
يحتاج مني أكون جنبه وهو بيتألم، بس ما أصلّح هذا الألم
تواجدي بيساعده هو يبدأ يتعافى من هذا الألم
فأنا لما أكون قريبة منه، صح مرة مؤلم
مزعج، يقهر، يضايق، يحق لك تتضايق، أخليه يتكلم يفضفض
يعرف أن أنا لو أيش ما قلت؛ عندي مساحة آمنة في البيت
بعدين أخليه يجرّب
ممكن يجرّب أن هو مثلًا يتراجع ما يواجهه
بعدين يلاقي أن عدم المواجهة خلّى صاحبه يتمادى
فإذن بتعلم أن لا ما راح أبعد؛ بواجه
ممكن يجرب يكلم مدرس؛ يخذله
فياخذ درس بالحياة، أن مو كل حولك بينقذك، فيه ناس تخذلك
وكثير من الدروس
احنا نحمي بأطفالنا حماية مفرطة كثير هذه الأيام
هذا اللي ألاحظه كثير
وهذا مضر على الأطفال؟
طبعًا، هو عنده مختبر يصنع منه كثير من المهارات
أنا لما أحدد هذه الخبرات ودائمًا أتدخل؛ ما خدمته
وأنا ما بعيش لهم العمر كله، وما بكون معاهم 24 ساعة
في حلقة سابقة كنت مع الدكتور «عبدالله السبيعي»
كان يقول إذا ما تعلم الطفل المهارات الاجتماعية وهو صغير
لن يتعلمها وهو كبير
فعلًا
وهو يعزو اليوم لكثير، أنه تلقى ناس نقول كبار
بس أنه ما عنده هذه المهارات الاجتماعية
لأنه فقدها هو صغير، لأنه كان محاط بدوائر ضيقة وصغيرة
فهل مثلًا أنك تأخذ طفلك في أماكن أكبر
مثلًا إذا كان ولد، تروح وتوديه مجالس الكبار
إذا كانت بنت مثل كذا
هل هذه جالسة تفيد؟ وللا هي مضرة بالنسبة للطفل؟
المفترض كل طفل يعيش عمره الحقيقي فقط وما يطلع من هذا؟
مرة ثانية، ما في إجابة كثيرة محددة
يعتمد مثلًا على مدى قابلية الطفل الاجتماعية، استعداده وغيره
ولكن بشكل عام، يفترض أن نعرض الأطفال لمجالس اجتماعية
لو الأب حب أن يأخذ ولده لمجلس الكبار
بالعكس، هذا الشيء يشجعه، لأنه يخليه يتعلم مثلًا
يخليه يشوف نماذج كبيرة من الكبار
يخليه يشوف أبوه في هذا الوسط الاجتماعي
البنت تشوف أمها مثلًا في جمعات عائلية
التواصل مع اختلاف الأجيال؛ ينمي، يكبّر
وكثير دراسات صارت أن الأطفال اللي عندهم تواصل عالي مع أجدادهم
عندهم ذكاء اجتماعي أعلى، عندهم خبرات اجتماعية ومهارات اجتماعية
أخذوها بسبب احتكاكهم بهذه البيئات
فبالعكس، احنا نبغى الأطفال من عمر صغير أن يتواجدوا في هذه البيئات
اليوم، المحتوى اللي على الإنترنت يأثر علينا كلنا، الكبار والصغار
بس بالنسبة للصغار تأثيره يصير أضخم
واحد، بيكون اللي هو عامل اللغة
بما أن معظم المحتوى اللي بيكون محتوى غير عربي
اثنين، وهو النقطة المهمة هنا
اللي هو المحتوى الثقافي والقيمي والمعرفي
فهي كلها على قيم نتفلكس وللا القيم غربية وغيره
وبكذا حتى فيه واحد من الأصدقاء
كان يقول أن بنته الظاهر كانت تسولف معه على الهالوين
وأنها تعرفه، وتقول ليش يسوون مثل كذا
فهو استغرب من معرفتها بهذا الشيء
قام سألها إذا تعرفين عيد الفطر؟
ما كانت تعرف عيد الفطر
واو!
يمكن أنها تعرف أن في شيء اسمه عيد
بس ما تعرف أيش يعني عيد الفطر
مو تفاصيل الهالوين
كيف اليوم نقدر نتعامل مع الموضوع
بالضبط. اليوم العالم قرية صغيرة
وفعلًا كمية الانفجار الثقافي والمعلوماتي لأطفالنا
صارت أسرع وأكبر
وهذا حتى كمان خلق فجوة ما بين كثير من الآباء وأبناءهم
ومشكلة هذه الفجوة، لأن ممكن الولد يطالع
أن أبوي ما يفهم أشياء كثير أنا أفهمها
فيشعر أن أنا متمكن وأعلى منه
الأب يحس أن أنا ما أفهم شيء
فبالتالي يربكه ويهلعه، يحس أن أنا فقدت السيطرة
بيعرفوا أشياء أنا ما أعرفها، فيبدأ يحس أن هو محدود
وهذه تخلق صراعات بينهم
لذلك لو جينا من أوائل الخط
نرجع مرة ثانية، ما المفروض يتعرضوا لهذا المحتوى
في أول عشر سنين بشكل مفرط
فتقليل عدد الساعات، تحديد المواقع اللي يدخلوا فيها
حجب هذه التطبيقات اللي تطلّع لهم كل شيء
مثل تيك توك وللا سناب شات وللا إنستقرام
هذه كلها تعمل لهم حماية للمستقبل
هل سهل يا عبدالرحمن؟ لا مرة مو سهل
أنا ما بحكي من برج عاجي
مرة ثانية، أنا أم وأعرف أني لما ما أسمح لهم يدخلوا لهذه الأشياء
ممكن أكون أنا الأم الوحيدة وسط كل الأمهات
فبالتالي يصير في ضغط عليهم، أيش معنى احنا؟
وهذه مهمة. فهنا مسألة الثبات مرة ثانية
كيف أثبت، كيف أهدأ وتكون رؤيتي أبعد من اللحظة الحالية
كيف أطوّل بالي وأستوعب انزعاجهم، وأعرف أن هذا انزعاج طفل
فما يسحبني جوّة انزعاجه، وأصير أنا كمان فايرة ومنزعجة مثله
بس خلاص واسكتوا، وللا بقوم
لا، كيف يصير عندنا هذه السعة الفكرية والعاطفية
أن أنا أحتوي هذا الانزعاج، بس أظل ثابتة
فمرة ثانية نرجع نقول، من البدايات أحاول أقنن قدر المستطاع
هذا يفترض يعطيني مساحة
وهنا عشان كذا نرجع نقول فيه أشياء مو بالفطرة
فيه أشياء لازم احنا نسويها مع أبناءنا
أن تصير عندي الساحة للعطاء مع أبنائي
أنا مرة أستغرب نفس الشيء
أيام ما كنت عايشة بأمريكا، كان في طفل سعودي عمره عشر سنين
فكان يوم عاشوراء كنا صايمين، كنا متجمعين عشان نفطر مع بعض
فهو بيسأل بنتي، ليش صايمين؟
فقالت له هذا اليوم اللي ربنا أنقذ فيه موسى عليه السلام
قال لها هو رب؟ فقالت له لا هو نبي
قال لها هو النبي حقنا؟
مسكينة بنتي طالعت وقالت لي ماما ما يعرف
وصدقًا ممكن كثير من الأهل يوصلوا أولادنا لعمر عشر
هذا عايش في أمريكا، سعودي؟
هو طفل سعودي، ولكن في أمريكا
فاحنا سؤال نسأل نفسنا
مين راح يوصّل هذا الإرث الكبير عن الأنبياء
وعن أسماء الله الحسنى، وعن هذه الأشياء، مين راح يوصلها؟
اليوم المدارس معاد صارت تلعب هذا الدور مثلًا
زمان كانت في جيل آبائنا وأجدادنا مثلًا
الجد، العم، إمام المسجد وغيره
اليوم هذا على عاتقي
فبالتالي نرجع نقول، احنا فعلًا اليوم يقع على عاتقنا
فما أسميها تربية حديثة. في الأخير هي ماهي...
بس اليوم أنا فعلًا أحتاج أخصص هذا الوقت
أنقل هذا التراث، وننقله من عمر مرة مبكر
أبناءنا لازم يعرفوا امتداد دينهم
هو أنت لما توحّد الله، ترى فيه أمم قبلها
قصص جميلة، حتى تكون مسلية للطفل
وفي نفس الوقت تبدأ تعطي له صورة
مني أنا كإنسان في هذا المعمورة. من فين جينا، كيف البداية
قد أيش بدري؟
من يوم ما يبدأ الطفل ينطق ويأخذ ويعطي بالكلام
ثلاث أو أربع سنين يختلف من استعداده
أنا مثلًا فيه من بناتي من ثلاث سنين بدأت فيه
بعضهم من أربع سنين ونص
أنتِ كأم تعرفي وكأب تقدّر، متى بيستوعب، بياخذ، أيش القدر
بس مهم أن احنا نوصّل
عشان نرجع مرة ثانية، الهالوين وعيد الفطر؛ هي مسؤوليتي أنا
لا أنتظر إعلام يوصلها لأولادي
أنا أحتاج أحكي له، أنا أحتاج أوصل هذه المعلومات
ومو بس مجرد تنظير وفلسفة، نحتاج نعيشها حقيقي معه
فيه نقطة مهمة قلتيها، وما أعرف كيف تتعاملين معها
كيف تتعاملين مع أطفالك هم الوحيدين اللي ما عندهم أجهزة
لما يروحوا عند أعمامهم وللا أخوالهم
ويلقوا كل الأطفال معهم أجهزة، ليش احنا لا؟
نسدد ونقارب مرة ثانية
ممكن نقول إذا أنتوا بتروحوا...
مرات يقولوا لي بنروح هناك وفيه لعبة بنلعبها كلنا مع بعض
إذا أنتِ عندك الإجازة الأسبوعية ساعة
هذه الساعة كم بتستخدميها في البيت
وكم منها تاخذي الجهاز وتروحي تلعبي معهم هناك؟
فأنت هنا تعلمه ترتيب الأولويات، وصناعة القرار، وحل المشكلات
فأنت سيبها لهم
أنتِ لكِ ساعة، والجهاز تلقائيًّا بتطبيق بينطفي
بطفّيه من عندي بينطفي، خلاص هذا الحد الزمني
فبالتالي يصير عندهم يسددوا ويقاربوا
هل كل الأيام نمشي بهذا المثال؟
لا، طبعًا تجي صعود وهبوط مثلًا
فيه أيام مثلًا ممكن والله قلنا ساعة
وأخذوا راحتهم صارت ساعتين
بس يعرف الطفل أن ليش...
وحاجة ثانية كمان مرة مهمة
مو بس والله ممنوع تتفرجوا أكثر من ساعة وللا من نص ساعة وبس
عشان تخلي طفلك حليف معك في هذا القانون
لا بد أنك تشرح له
مثلًا بناتي يعرفوا أيش الخطر اللي يصير على أدمغتهم
أوريهم صور الأدمغة
الناقلات العصبية، أيش يصير في الدماغ
لما يلعب ألعاب فيديو لثلاث ساعات أو لعب ربع ساعة
كيف الفرق؟ كيف الاندفاعية في الدماغ؟
«الدوبامين» كيف يشتغل؟
وهذه كلها معلومات علمية، بس نبسطها لهم
بحيث يعرف أنه صح، أنا من مصلحتي أني أنا أوقف
صح، مو مرة عاجبني هذا القرار، بس أنا فاهم ليش
بالنسبة للغة، اليوم التلقي كثير بالإنقليزي
كثير من المدارس وحتى من الروضات
والمدارس ما قبل الابتدائية، كلها بالإنقليزي
نادرًا، فيه بعضهم الميزة الوحيدة لهم أنهم يدرسون بالعربي
صح
فمشكلة، كيف أثر اللغة على الطفل؟
مهمة جدًّا، وترى اللغة ماهي بس مجرد لغة
أنا أذكر في أمريكا مرة انطلب مني موضوع أبحث عنه
وكنت صراحة منزعجة جدًّا من الدكتور اللي طلبه
لأنه كان علم النفس اللغوي
وكان مرة صعب ومعقد، ولكن ما تعلمته أبهرني كثير ومرة تفاجأت
أعطيك تجربة مرت علي وأنا بعمل هذا البحث
جابوا ياباني وأمريكي، وحطوا قدامهم فازة وكسروها
واللي كسرها اسمه «جون»
فطلبوا من الياباني يقول أيش صار، ومن الأمريكي أيش صار
الاثنين وصفوها بطريقة مختلفة
الياباني قال «جون» كسر الفازة، الأمريكي قال انكسرت الفازة
ليش اختلفت تركيبة اللغة ووصفها
يختلف على حسب أيش تركيبتك المجتمعية والثقافية
الأمريكي، مجتمع فردي. ويمشوا بالأحداث والرأسمالي
وهذه كلها تشكّل تركيبة اللغة
الياباني بالنسبة لهم يحطوا الفعل في آخر الجملة، ليش؟
عشان من ثقافتهم لازم تجلس وتسمع، والشخص مهم
وبعدين الحدث يصير مهم
لما احنا نمارس اللغة ترى هي مو أنا بوصّل رسالة
هي تحمل قيم ومنظومة اجتماعية
فخسارة أبناءنا للغة هي مش خسارة للغة مجرد لغة
هي تعكس تركيبة اجتماعية وأشياء كثيرة
كثير من الأهل يقولون أهم شيء هو يتواصل
أهم شيء يعرف يتكلم، وأهم شيء أقدر أفهم عليه
بإنقليزي، بصيني، بعربي، باللي يكون
بس احنا ما نعرف أن اللغة تعكس ثقافتنا
كثير من الموروث اللذي يخصنا العربي أو الإسلامي
موجود في لغتنا العربية
ومهما نقلنا للغة الإنقليزية؛ ما راح يوصل بنفس العمق اللي يوصله هناك
هل هو تحدي؟ نعم وتحدي مرة كبير وماهو سهل
لأنك فعلًا بتعرّضهم الآن
التعليم الجيد للأبناء بيعتمد بشكل مباشر
وأساسي على اللغة الإنقليزية
بس دائمًا نقول هذا يفترض يكون أولوية
أو ما أبغى أسميه هَم، بس حاجة لازم تكون دائمًا حاضرة
أن اللغة تعكس ثقافتك. كيف تحس بهويتك
فجزء من بناء الهوية يعتمد على اللغة
بالنسبة للغة الإنقليزية كان فيه اللغة، وفيه جانب القيم تكلمنا عنه
بس فيه نقطة من التحديات اللي تجي للآباء
سواءً مثلًا من الآيات وغيرها
وهذه سهل شرحها وسهل التعامل معها
بس فيه أشياء مثلًا ثانية
وخصوصًا أنها اليوم أصبحت موجودة في كل المحتوى للأطفال وغير الأطفال
واللي هي مثلًا المثلية الجنسية
كيف يقدر يتعاملوا مع مفهوم المثلية الجنسية وشرحها للأطفال؟
أول حاجة لازم نحن كأباء وأمهات
نكون على وعي صحيح تجاه هذا الموضوع
ووعي حقيقي ومتشعب
معاد يكفي أن أقول هذا حرام وخلاص لا نسويه
واللي يمارس هذه الفاحشة هذا جزاؤه
على أجيال من قبل مرت
وما كان فيه هذا التعرض الكبير الإعلامي
فهذه المعلومة كانت كافية لنا
إلى فترة الأجيال كانت قريبة
اليوم مع هذا الانفتاح؛ صارت الأوراق داخلة في بعضها
هو تولد كذا، هو حر، أيش فيها لو صار كذا، وغيرها من الأمور
لذلك مهم جدًّا أن احنا نفهم، نفهم من اللي ممكن يكون عنده فعلًا خلل
أو ما أبغى أسميها خلل، ولكن هو وُلِد بهذه المشكلة
اللي تحتاج إلى تصحيح الجنس أو تثبيت الجنس
وهذا غير عن تغيير الجنس، هذا شيء وهذا شيء
أطفالنا لازم اليوم يعرفوا أيش الفرق بين هذا وهذا
أيش هذه الإسهالات الطبية اللي تستدعي التصحيح الجنسي
وهي نسبتها جدًّا قليلة
وكيف تكون؟ أما بالصبغة الكروموسومية أو غيره
وترى اليوم أطفالنا أذكياء
قادرين يفهموا هذه المعلومات كلها من عمر ممكن سبعة أو ثمانية سنين
خاصة إذا هم تعرّضوا وعندهم الأسئلة
فأنا لازم أشبعها، ما أتركهم للإعلام
اللي يبغى يعمل هذا التغيير
هنا لازم فيه نظرة شمولية ومنصفة
تجريم هذه الفئة مثلًا أو بس مجرد لعنها أو رفضها؛ هذا ما بيحل شيء
لأن هو لما بيطلع في المقابل على التيك توك والإنستقرام أو أي تطبيقات
بيبدأ يشوف طرح مو مثل هذا الطرح
مو طرح أسود وأبيض، غلط وصح
بيبدأ يسمع مرة كلام تفصيلي كثير
إذن أنا أقابله بكلام تفصيلي كثير
هذا الشخص مثلًا اللي حاسس أن أنا ما أبغى أكون ولد
بس أنا جسدي جسد ولد
فيه أسباب كثيرة عميقة نفسية مثلًا
ممكن يكون بناء الهوية الجنسية من عمر مبكر ما صار فيه رعاية
أو الوالد من نفس الجنس كن نموذج مشوّه جدًّا أو غائب
فردة فعل أنا ما أبغى أكون هذا النموذج
أو ممكن البيئة الاجتماعية ما تحترم أو تسحق هويتي مثلًا
فبالتالي أنا عشان أتمرد؛ أبغى أكون الهوية الثانية
ممكن تكون خبرات جنسية مبكرة تعرضت لها من نفس الجنس
فبالتالي أشعر أن أنا ما بنجذب
وما راح أمارس الممارسات إلا من نفس الجنس
لأن هذه هي أول خبرة صارت عندي مثلًا
ففيه لها أسباب
ممكن يكون تحرش؟
ممكن يكون، ومرات ما يكون تحرش، هو يبدأ كأنه تحرش
وبعد كذا ينساق الطفل يصير جزء من هذه الممارسات
وكثير حالات مرت علي بهذه الطريقة
فيجي يقول أنا عندي اضطراب الهوية الجنسية
بس لما نجي نفصل الحالة، أنت ما عندك اضطراب الهوية الجنسية
هو يقول أنا ما أقدر مثلًا أمارس الجنس إلا مع نفس الجنس
فلما نجي نشوف التاريخ التفصيلي
نلاقي أن كل الممارسات صارت من عمر صغير من نفس الجنس
وكان عنده ضعف في المعرفة أو تشوّف المعرفة
أو غياب المعرفة عن العلاقة الصحية اللي تصير مع الجنس الآخر
فغابت المعرفة هنا وتعززت بالممارسة هنا
فصارت الممارسة مشوّهة
هذه الحوارات التفصيلية نحن بحاجة لطرحها مع أبناءنا
كثير من الناس أفهم مرة كيف تتحرّج
والموضوع صعب يصير عليها
لكن دائمًا نقول إن ما كنت أنا المصدر الأول والآمن في هذه الحوارات
تأكد أن ساحات مخيفة وغير، راح تتولى الإجابة عليها
أنا لما أشوف مثلًا بالعيادة يجوني مراهقين
يحكي عن عمليات تغيير الجنس بكل بساطة
ومعلومات طبية وكلها تكون غلطة
من فين جايبها؟ مصادر كثير طبية
طبية، بس هي ماهي طبية، يجيبها من مواقع أجنبية
يجي الأب وجنبه مسكين فاتح فمه
مو فاهم ولا كلمة من اللي بيقولها ولده
بالتالي، أنت لازم تعرف هنا بالضبط
أيش طبيعة العملية اللي بتصير
هي عبارة عن استئصال أعضاء
أنت ما راح تصير رجل بالكامل ولا أنثى بالكامل
وغيرها من هذه التفاصيل اللي احنا نحتاجها
يسوّق كثير مثلًا في الإعلام لأطفالنا أن وُلدوا بهذه الطريقة
لا أحد يولد مثلي الجنسية
كل الأبحاث، أحدث الأبحاث صارت وجدًّا موضوعية
ومراجعات منهجية وكثير
يمكن المجال ما يعطيني الآن أفصّل فيها
لكن كلها تقول ما في أحد يولد بهذا التوجّه
هذا يُخلق مع الخبرات
ما في أحد يولد مثلي الجنس؟
لا، أبدًا. وفيه تسويق كبير أن لها دخل بالجينات الوراثية
صارت محاولات بحثية كثير جدًّا من السبعينيات
وكل الخلاصات، حتى اللي كانوا منحازين
هم نفسهم يكونوا مثلًا يتبعوا لجمعية مثلي الجنسية
هم حاولوا أن يثبتوها، الخلاصات تقول ما وصلنا
لا فيه جين مسؤول
حتى التوأم المتطابق اللي يكونوا مثلًا...
وصارت دراسات كثير في السويد وهولندا
أضخم دراسة صارت في أستراليا، كان 4000 آلاف مثليين فيها
ما لقوا أن فيه أي جينات وراثية أو أي شيء
فيه كتاب رائع جميل اسمه
(My Genes Made Me Do It) «جيناتي خلتني أعملها»
وكيمياء حيوية اللي كاتبين الكتاب اثنين
ترى كل سنتين يحدّثوه بأجدد الأبحاث
أقرأ الكتاب من الجلد للجلدة، ما تلاقي أي بحث علمي يقول
هذه المعلومات، من حق أبناءنا علينا أن نوصلهم هي
يعرفوها مننا
عشان لما تجيهم كذا 30 ثانية في تيك توك
تقول لهم ولدت كذا؛ يعرفوا ويكون عندهم العقل الناقد العلمي
اللي مؤسس صح
لما نقول مثلًا أن هي مشكلة في الهرمونات
مين الحالات الطبية؟ وأيش طبيعة الهرمونات؟ وكيف تكون؟
هذه المعلومات العلمية، اليوم نحن بحاجة
أعتقد أنها صارت ضرورة أكثر من أنها شيء ثانوي
أن احنا نطرحها مع أبناءنا
وتكون عندنا الشجاعة الكافية يا عبدالرحمن
أننا لما نطرحها؛ نترك مساحة نسمع أسئلتهم وأفكارهم
لأن ممكن كثير من الأهل يخافوا، أنه بيجادلني
خليه يجادل، خليه يعرف أن هذا البيت فيه ساحة كافية للحوار
لأن ممكن يروح إلى ساحات حوار ثانية
ممكن تغسل دماغه أو توصل له معلومات غير صحية
بس اللي تقوليه كلام صعب برضه
بكذا يتطلب أن الأب والأم يكون عندهم معرفة
في رد الحجج القوية اللي تجي من كل مكان
وأنا ما أقدر. فعلًا ما أقدر تخيل أن كل الناس
يكون عندها هذا الكم من المعرفة أني أجلس أرد على كل شيء
صح، بس أنا ما أقدر أرد على كل شيء
لكن أقدر أتعلم عشان أرد
لو جاء ولدي مثلًا وقال لي معلومة
أو سألني سؤال وأنا فعلًا ما أعرف إجابتها
هنا دائمًا نقول للأهل، بيّنوا لهم أنكم ما تعرفوا كل شيء
عادي، بالعكس خليه يعرف أنك أنت إنسان قابل للتعلم طول العمر
قول له سؤالك مرة حلو ومرة مهم، ببحث عن إجابته
أو تعال أنا وأنت نبحث عن إجابته
وأبحث في مصادر علمية موثقة
ممكن أزودكم حتى بمواقع
أعرف هو للأسف حتى هذه اللحظة المختصين
أو المحتوى العربي العلمي المحكم في هذا الموضوع
جدًّا ضئيل، بس لا يعني أن هو مو موجود
فيه محاولات من مختصين يحاولون يحكوا
عن هذا الموضوع بحيادية وعلمية سليمة
فإذن أنا دوري لما أسمع هذا السؤال
أحتاج أبحث عن الإجابة؛ عشان أجي أجاوب ولدي عليها
كل الكتب والدراسات اللي تهم، بنحطها في نشرة الحلقة هذه
بس والله بحس أنه ببقى تحته
لو جاء ابني عنده ميول مثلية، كيف أتعامل معاه؟
دائمًا نقول احتوِّ، والاحتواء ما يجي في يوم وليلة
أولًا تواصل مع مشاعرك أنت نفسها، لما تعرف هذا الشيء
ممكن يجيك حزن أو غضب أو ارتباك
أشعر بكل مشاعرك
لأن هذه مشكلتنا، مرات نختزل المشاعر
وهذا ممكن يبدأ يؤذينا أو أنا الآن غضبان
بدل ما أفهم غضبي؛ أقوم أصب الغضب على ولدي
أو أصب الغضب على الإعلام أو على غيره
فاحنا نحتاج إلى التوازن هذا مرة مهم
عشان كذا نقول التواصل مع النفس هذا مرة مهم، فهذه أول خطوة
ثاني خطوة، لازم أؤكد على ابني
أن مهما كان توجهك أو اختياراتك تبقى ابني
وهذا ترى نهج رباني
نوح عليه السلام، من أولي العزم من الرسل، وكم استمرت دعوته
إلى آخر لحظة، ما فرّق بينه وبين ولده اللي اختلف تمامًا عنه
إلا الموج «وَحالَ بَيْنَهُمَا الْمَوْجُ»
فهذا يعطينا مؤشر أن أنا دوري أني أثبت
في حبي وفي رعايتي وفي احتوائي
راح احتوي وبفضل دائمًا أبوه
فهنا كثير آباء يهددوا بالحب
ما بتصير ولدي، بتبرّئ منك
تعرف شيء تعال تبرئ مني؛ بتلاقي...
أنا حالات مرت علي لشباب وبنات هنا
لما عرضوا لأهاليهم هذا التوجّه ورفضوهم أهاليهم
من باب ألوِّ ذراعه أو أبتزّه عاطفيًّا، تعرف أيش صار؟
فيه مواقع كثير تقول لهم بس صوّر لنا صورة جواز سفرك
تجيك تذكرتك على طول، عائلة بتتبنّاك هناك
ندخلك في نظام التعليم، وكل شيء مجانًا لك
وراحوا كثير للأسف من أولادهم وبناتهم، ليش؟
لأنه ما احتووهم. وهناك احتووهم
فعشان كذا دائمًا نقول الاحتواء مهم
وأحاول بقدر المستطاع أساعده يفهم هذا الشعور أكثر
قبلما تصلّح التوجه؛ حاول أن أنت تساعد نفسك وولدك وتفهم أكثر
ولما بتحاول تفهم الجذور؛ طريق مؤلم
أنا أحكي من واقع عيادي، مؤلم جدًّا
لأن ممكن يكون فيه تاريخ مثلًا من الإساءات الجنسية
أو الإساءات العاطفية أو الإهمال الوالدي بحس نية
أو كره ثقافته أو قبيلته أو مجتمعه
وأنا من نفس هذه القبيلة أنا وولدي
لما أنت راح تقوله؛ أنا ما أحس إن أنا أنتمي له
هذا كلام قاسي، بس لازم يصير عندي العافية النفسية
اللي أتحمل الاستماع والاحتواء، ولا نستعجل
ودائمًا نقول النتيجة ماهي بإيدنا
بس يتصلح؟
إيه، ممكن يتصلح، وممكن ما يتصلح
متى يكون يتصلح؟ متى يكون ما يتصلح؟
عوامل مرة كثير يا عبد الرحمن
حقيقي أنا مروا علي كثير ناس، سبحان الله، تصلّح
التوجه تغير تمامًا
وفيه ناس أخذت سنوات، وفيه ناس أخذت شهور
وفي ناس تصلح وبعدين يمروا بانتكاسة ويرجعوا
وفيه ناس تمامًا ما تصلحوا
عوامل مرة كثير، عوامل مثلًا ممكن العلاج نفسه
البيئة الاجتماعية، العاطفية، التواجد الوالدي، الاستيعاب
أشياء مرة كثير
وأولًا وأخيرًا هي إرادة الله حقيقي
الناس اللي ما قدروا يتعالجوا
هل بهذا نفهم أن فيه ناس كذا يولدوا؟
لا، هو ما أحد يولد بهذا التوجّه
هو ممكن يقولك أنا من يوم كنت صغير أحس أن أنا كذا
هذه الذاكرة الروائية
بس الذاكرة الإجرائية اللي تخزن الخبرات
الاجتماعية والعاطفية في أول خمس سنين
هي تخزنها كخبرات عاطفية واجتماعية مو لفظية
فأنت تحس، بس ما تدري أيش صار في أول خمس سنين مثلًا
الذاكرة الروائية اللي هي تنشط بعد ستة سنين
الولد لما يجي على أول ابتدائي، يحكيك أيش المدرس أيش سوّى معاه
لكن لعمر ثلاث سنين يرجع من الروضة ما يقدر يحكيك
لأنه عنده بس ذاكرة إجرائية
فالذاكرة الإجرائية تكون خزنت أو عاشها
أنه كان ولد، ولكن مر بخبرات أثرت على شعوره تجاه نفسه
بس يبدأ يذكر نفسه من عند الذاكرة الروائية
الموضوع حقيقي معقد ماهو بالبساطة
لذلك مرة ثانية نقول طرحه بسطحية
أنه أما ملعون أو حرام أو كذا
أو طرحه أن خلاص هو هو مثل ماهو
يعني يا أبيض يا أسود؛ مرة نجحف هذا الموضوع حقه
حقيقةً يحتاج لهذا العمق في الفهم والرحمة والحكمة كمان فيها
الله يعطيك العافية
الله يعافيك يارب
شكرًا جزيلًا
الله يسلمك يارب
شكرًا لكم، شكرًا لعمر الشنقيطي في إعداد الحلقة
عبدالرحمن عبود خلف الكاميرات
وفي التسجيل الصوتي عبدالعزيز المزي
والهندسة الصوتية محمد الحسن
والتحرير محمد نور شمّت
وفي التلوين عبدالمجيد العطاس
وإدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نورة السبيعي
ومنتج البرنامج أيمن الحمّادي
وفي إدارة تحرير البرنامج أسيل با عبدالله
هذا في فنجان، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل؛ ألقادم
الأستاذ أيمن على مشارف...
أنت اللي تواصلت معاي؟ لأن فيه اثنين أيمن صح وللا يتهيأ لي؟
صح، صح
واحد ممكن يغيّر اسمه. اثنين، أن الرجل يبغى...
حطيت لي تاريخ، بعدها أن يجب أني أتزوج
في السنة الجاية، وللا 2025؟
2025، أنا قاعد أقول هذه الحلقة تفيدني بعد
طيب الحمد لله
هو يبغى الحلقة مو بعشان...
مفترض أنك تسوي حلقة كيف تبحث عن الزوجة
بس هو يبغى كيف يربى أولاده وباقي ما جات زوجته
أصعب الثاني، الأول بسيط
تربية أطفال والله أنه شيء مزعج ومربك
ما أفهم ولا أي شيء
أحس أن فيه كثير ناس مؤخرًا صاروا يفكرون فكرة أنه ما يحتاج...
حتى صارت فكرة دارجة مرة بسبب الإزعاج هذا
ازعاج التربية والعبء وما أدري إيه
لأن الإنسان صار يحس أن أنا كل شيء أقدر أتحكم فيه
بس في الحقيقة ما تقدر تتحكم
أنا أحس هذا الخوف؛ شعور التمكين العالي اللي وصله اليوم الإنسان
فأنا يا أضبطها 100% يطلعوا أولادي كويسين، يا ما بسوي
هذه ماهي مسؤوليتك
فأنا المنتج الأخير لأولادي ترى ماهي مسؤوليتي
أنا لو أم وفهمت هذه المعادلة؛ أتوقع الوالدية بتصير أريح علينا
ونرجع لزمن اللي بالبركة، اللي كانوا يسيبوهم بالبركة
صح، لأن فيه جزء من هذه البركة احنا نبغى نشيلها
وأحس حتى هذول اللي ما يبغون ينجبون
لو يفكر بشكل نفعي بحت، أنك تحتاج الولد ذا بالنهاية
طبعًا
لو بتاخذها بدون أي شعور، بدون أي عاطفة
أنك تحتاجه بالنهاية، بكرة تشيّب ما في أحد
بس أنك لما تجي تفكر فيها خصوصًا بعد الحلقة
بعد الحلقة فكرت خلاص بنضم...
للي ما ينجبون
اللا إنجابيين، لا أمزح
مثل اللي فيه اللازواجيين
كمان؟
أيوة. أمس كنت في الكوافير وجالسة سامعة اثنين بيحكوا
قالت أنتِ متزوجة أو مو متزوجة
المهم الحوار أخذ منحى أن احنا ما نحتاج نتزوج
أنا مستقلة وعندي راتبي وما أبغى أحد يتحكم فيّ
بس هذا يضرب في أصل الاحتياجات الأساسية للإنسان
آدم كان في جنة الله، وبعدين ما حس بالأُنس إلا بوجود حواء
وهذه هي حقيقة الإنسان وهذه تركيبتنا كبشر
احنا ترى مرة بنشوّه هذه التركيبة بشعورنااللاستقلال العالي
ونفس الشيء اللي اللا إنجابيين، أنا ما أحتاج أطفال
لا، أنت تحتاجهم وهم يحتاجوك
بيندموا يوم لا ينفع الندم
أيوة، سبحان الله
بس أنه صعب، مو سهلة عملية التربية
لأن أقدر أتكلم، بس أنتِ ما تقدري تتكلمي
لأن عندك تجربة، وهذه حقيقة
بس الناس تتكلم ليه تعطي ولدك جوال؟
بس صدق، إذا ما أعطيته؛ حياتي بتختلف
إذا أعطيت جوال، الحياة مختلفة تمامًا
هادئ، ما فيه إزعاج، حياة أروق
بس مجرد إني أشيل الجوال، 200% من جهدي لازم أسويه
تقدري تقولي أنه حقيقة، هذا دورك طيب
أيوة
شوف أنا لما رحت اليابان، وشفت كيف هي ثقافة المجتمع
أنا انبهرت، قلت لبناتي أرسلكم بعثات إخلاقية على اليابان
روحوا أجلسوا هناك وشوفوا العالم كيف عايشة
نص الناس تبغى تروح أصلًا
هادئين. أظن أنا كنت الوحيدة اللي أعصب في الشارع
كله هادئ، فعلًا هي ثقافة مجتمعية
صح أنا ما أقول لا، بس أرجع أقول أن هذه المشكلة
أن أنا بصير مثل كل الناس ما بختلف عنهم
أنا مثلًا ما عندي تأنيب ضمير لما أولادي يروحوا
مثلًا جمعة عائلة وما عندهم أجهزتهم، فين المشكلة طيب؟
والعائلة كلها معهم أجهزتهم؟
طبعًا العائلة كلها معها أجهزتها، كل واحد داخل وشايله
بس شوف أنا مثلًا لما يقولوا لي بناتي
ماما كل صاحباتنا لما يصير عمرهم عشر سنين ياخذوا الجوال
قلت هم نظامهم العائلي مو مثل نظام عائلتنا
فيعرف الطفل أن هذا نظام وهذا نظام
ولا يعني انطبق عليهم، انطبق علينا
شوف هي فيها تحدي، بس طولة البال لو جبناها بالعامي
وبعدين حط في بالك، أن الله يربي معانا
أنت في الأخير تحط اللي تقدر عليه، والمنتج ماهو منك
فيه أتذكر «مدحت عامر» مدري متى هو يعطي الجوالات، من يتذكر؟
بس أنه يقول أنا أفتّش جواله، ما في شيء اسمه عنده خصوصية
طفلي ما عنده خصوصية حتى يصير ثمانية عشر سنة
لا يكلمني، ما في شيء اسمه خصوصية
هو صح، لأن أنت بالأخير بتطلقه في العالم الافتراضي هذا
بدون وجودك معاه، ترى مرعب
بس متى أوقّف؟
هذا هو السؤال الحلو، دائمًا بناتي يقولي لي مثلًا
أيش العمر اللي ممكن ناخذ فيه جوالات؟
أقول لهم يعتمد على نضجكم، وروني نضجكم
لما أحس أنكم تقدروا تاخذوا قرارات صح
تقدروا تضبطوا نفسكم، تمتلكوا من العقل النقدي
ما يكفي أن يشعرني بالأمان
ذيك الساعة أيش يكون عمرك، ثلاثة عشر أو أربعة عشر ما راح يفرق
كم عمرك أكبر البنات؟
أكبرهم خمسة عشر
ما شاء الله، بدون جوال للحين؟
العام الماضي أخذت جوال
والحمد لله، ما كان فيه صراع أبدًا
كانت عارفة أنه لما تخرجي مثلًا وأنا ما أكون معك تركتك في مكان
أنا عندي جوال إضافي يروح معاكِ، عشان تتصلي
عندها تيك تكوك؟
أظن دحين اللي صار عندها
وبرضه لازم يصير فيه إشراف
أحتاج عيني تكون موجودة، لأنه ممكن تاخذوا قرارات مو مكتملة الأركان
واحنا نساعدكم تكملوها
وهذا هو، أنا ما أقول أنا براقبكم
أنا بدل ما أقول أراقبكم، أقول أحتاج أشرف عليكم
أنتوا تحتاجوا إلى دعمي، مو رقابتي
أشرف عليكم
إشراف، أيوة
فمن باب يحسوا أني أثق بكم
وتروحوا فيه، بس أنا لازم أكون معكم فيها
لأن ممكن ما تأخذوا قرارات كثير صحيحة
وأنا أقدر أساعدكم فيها
وبرضه ماهي سهلة، تسدد وتقارب
فيه قرارات تاخذها بنتي، مثلًا اجتماعية مع صداقات ما تعجبني تمامًا
وأنك تمسك نفسك عشان تسويه صعب
بس بعدين بعد فترة تقول والله أنتِ صح
طبعًا لو تشوف كيف ترجع هبة المكاوية
قلت لك، بس أرجع أقول أني انبسط
أنها خاضت التجربة ووصلت لهذه القناعة
مرة تتطلب نفس طويل واستيداع عند الله
كيف أستودعها؟ يا رب أنت عالم أن حمايتك ورعايتك ما نستغنى أبدًا
ما أقدر أحمل طول الوقت
بس ما تتوقف أقصد نهائيًّا، خلاص أنا معاد لي دخل؟
أنا ما أقدر أمنع ولدي وعمره خمسة وعشرين على الدخان
أقدر أمنعه وعمره خمسة عشر، أقدر أتحكم بهذا التصرف
بس متى أصير خلاص اللي...
بس هل من يكون عمره خمسة وعشرين، تقدر تتدخل؟
إذا الرجل صار عمره خمسة وعشرين
خمسة وعشرين ما تقدر توقفه إذا هو يبغى
هل لك دور فيه أنك توقفه؟
وللا عادي أن تعرف أن ما عندك دور وخلاص انتهى؟
هي أشكال الأدوار هي هذه كمان نقطة
أن أدوارنا تتغير شكلها
أنا مثلًا الآن مقدم رعاية 100% لو عمره سنتين
بس وعمره عشرين، أنا مقدمة الرعاية بشكل النصح أو القرب
فالرعاية تاخذ شكل مختلف
فأنا بخمسة وعشرين سنة ممكن أقول له حرام عليك، صحتك
فكر أنك...، ارسل له مثلًا تطبيق يساعده
اللي بسويه كذا من بعيد لبعيد
لأني أعرف أنه خلاص الحياة بتبدأ تاخذه باستقلالية
وأتقبل هذه الاستقلالية، كثير من الأهل ما يتقبلوها
لو ابتزيته عاطفيًّا؟
لا
ليش؟
لأنك بتؤذيه عاطفيًّا
طيب هو يبطّل دخان، أنا أحبه
كيف تبتزه عاطفيًّا؟ قول لي أيش، منت ولدي مثلًا لو دخنت؟
كل مرة يتكلمني أزعل عليه
غير راضي عنه
أنا ماني راضي عنك يا حيوان، الين تبطّل دخان
طيب استنى، أول شيء حيوان أنت كسرت الكرامة، هذا واحد
لا، عمره خمسة وعشرين يعني بسيطة
قولي أن عمره خمسة وعشرين وقلت له كذا
أنا ماني راضي عنك، أنت عاق
لا، هو ماهو عاق
أنا ماني راضي عنك
أنا أقول لك، عنك هذه صعبة، ماني راضي عن التدخين
إيه. بس أنا ما برضى عنك الين تبطل الدخان
بس مو على كيفك، لأنه في الأخير رضاك...
تبغى تبتزّه؛ ترى أنت...
بيصير ما يفرق
ما بيفرق معاه
بس أنا أبغاه يبطّل
بيدخن من وراك
أنا قرايبي مثل كذا يسوون
أنا ما بدخن قدامك أبد، ولا بسوي شيء
بس أنك تدري أن أنا أدخّن من بعيد، وأنت تدري وممشيها
مثل كذا يسوون
مهم أن الرسالة توصل، أن أنا أحبك بس أنا ما أحب هذا
بس أنا من حبي لك أني ما أبغاك تموت
طيب قولها كذا
إيه، فعشان كذا؛ بطّل
ليه ما يمنعهم، هذه هي المشكلة يستخدم العنف كسلاح أولي
بس مشكلة، الابتزاز العاطفي صدق والله
إذا أنا قلت له أنا ماني راضي عنك الين تبطّل كذا
ما أدري هو أيش جالس يسوي
أيوة، خلاص يبدأ يحس أن أنا الدخان
أبويا ما يشوف فيّ إلا الشخص المدخن
بطّل الدخان طيب
كذا صح؟
خلاص ابتزّه أيش نقدر نسوي لك يعني
لا، بس تخيلي بنتك تدخن
أنا بناتي مرات يبتزوني بهذه الأسئلة
مثلًا مثل كذا لو دخّنا، لو مش عارف إيه
أقول بفضل أحبك، بس ما بحب هذا التصرف اللي بتسويه
وبفضل أنصح وأنصح ما راح أيأس
إيه، ما بتتوقفي عن الزّن
ما بوقّف عن الزن، فضل وبفضل
بس ما بقعد أجلدهم عاطفيًّا، فهمت عليّ؟
بس كيف تقدري تحولي؟ تخيلي أنها... والله أني لأنجن
تخيلي يلا أنت كذا تكلمي بنتك
عمرها الحين مثلًا ثلاثة وعشرين
ومعها زقارة، ما بقدر أحب
يلا أنا أحبك، بس يلا كملي زقارتك، تبغين طفاية يا بنتي؟
لا، هنا ذيك الساعة أفرض قوانيني
قدامي ما يصير تدخين، هذا المنظر
ومن حقي أن أنا أكون مرتاحة كأم معاكِ
عشان كذا في الأجيال اللي قبلنا، ما يدخّن قدام الأب
مثلًا احنا مجتمع مكة، من الجرائم الكبرى
أن الراجل يدخّن قدام أبوه أو يشيش قدام أبوه، عيب مرة
لأن كأنك أنت بتمارس غلط قدام أبوك؛ تكسر هيبته
فهذه الثقافة نحتاج حتى أولادنا يعرفوها
أنا أعرف أنك تسوي غلط بس لا تسويه قدامي
لأنه يؤذيني أني أشوفك كذا
يؤذيني الدخان، بكون «مدخنة سلبية» بتؤذيني وتضرني
فأيوة هنا لك الحق كأب أنك تقول
كذا ممتاز
فيه نوع من الابتزاز العاطفي ماهو على شيء غلط
اللي هو أيش اختار جامعة؟ أنت تصير دافور
انا هذه الملابس ما تعجبني، أو أبغاك...
أتوقع هنا يصير الموضوع معقد
إيه، الولد يبغى يطوّل شعره
إيه هنا يصير الابتزاز
الولد لا تطوّل شعرك
هذه أنا أحس كلها برضها من أشكال شوية...
عشان كذا دائمًا أقول ترك الساحة لشوية استقلالية
ترى تربك كثير من الأهل
والله؟
أيوة، لأن فيه جزئين فينا يشتغل وقت الوالدية: الحامي والمتحكم
نشعر أن هذه الجزئين اللي فينا هي اللي بتدرك أمور التربية
بس في الحقيقة أنت ما تقدر تكون حامي طول الوقت
ولا متحكم طول الوقت
خلِّ هذه الدورين يتراجعوا شوية يرتاحوا
وخلِّ مثلًا العادل، المتفهم، الملاحظ
الملاحظ أصعب شيء، تجلس تلاحظ وتمسك نفسك
هذا مجتمعنا صعب عليه
نشمّر أكمامنا ولازم نتحكم، لازم نحمي
فهذه من الأشياء اللي نحتاج أن احنا ندرب نفسنا عليها
ماهي سهلة، أنا أقول لك هي، وأنا مرات لما ألاحظ
طبعًا من جوّايا أبغى أتحرك، أبغى أتصرف
بس ارجع وأقول خليهم يأخذوا الساحة
وأدخّل شوية المتحكم بقدر البسيط
نرجع، لازم نتواصل مع نفسنا
أيش سالفة «مشاكل الأبوة» و«مشاكل الأمومة» ؟
كيف تصير؟ أحس كل الناس صار عندهم «مشاكل الأبوة» نفسها
توّي أنا أدري عن المصطلح
بالضبط. ترى كان ياخذ أشكال ثانية
بس دحين تقولب
أيش أشكاله الثانية؟
أشكالها ثانية مثلا «مشاكل الأبوة» مثل عدم الشعور بالثقة مع الزوج مثلًا
أو الخوف الدائم من الزوج مثلًا أو التمرد على الزوج
أو دائمًا تحس أبغى أجذب انتباه الرجال بأي شكلٍ كان
زمان الله يرحم، كانت تلفونات وبطايق
دحين بالجوالات والتطبيقات
هي تاخذ أشكال، الشكل يتغير
ما كان له مصطلح، بس كانت فيه مشاكل
تعكس أن هذه البنت ما تواجد الأب تواجد آمن في حياتها
فترك هذا الفراغ، فلما كبرت أبغى أعبيه
فطبعًا أعبيه بطريقة غير صحية
فيه ناس كبرت وما عندها هذا التواجد
بس عبته بطريقة صحية
قدرت تتسامح مع هذا الفقد
قدرت تعرف أن كنت أحتاج الحماية من الوالد
كيف أوفر هذه الحماية من وسائل آمنة
من نفسي ومن دوائر آمنة قريبة مني
فيه ناس شقّت الطريق بشكل آمن
وفيه ناس شقّته بطريقة غير آمنة
«مشاكل الأمومة» تصير عند الأولاد كمان نفس الشيء
يصير عنده تعلّق مثلًا لسيدات كبار
يصير يبغى يجذب الستات الكبار
لأنه حس أن أمي ما كانت تشوفني بنظرة حلوة وللا مقدرة
كانت غايبة مثلًا
الجانب الأنثوي هذا ما كان في حياتي
فيبدأ يبحث عن الإناث، نسميها (صايع) وللا...
بس في الحقيقة هو الجانب الأنثوي مثلًا من الأنثى الأولى في حياته
ما كانت فيه بشكل مشبع، فبالتالي يحاول يشبعها
بس هل كل الرجال كذا؟ كان نص المجتمع أو ثلاث أرباعه طلع مثلًا...
بس فيه ناس أشبعتها وهذبتها وعبّت هذا الفراغ بشكل جيد
وهذول اللي عبّوه بشكل آمن؛ هم اللي عرفوا يتواصلوا مع نفسهم
أعرف أن فيه عندي مشكلة، أعرف أن فيه عندي...
فعرفوا يتعاملوا معاه
فدائمًا أقول، سبحان الله، لما الله يحطنا في هذه...
كل الناس، كلنا احنا ما اخترنا أباءنا، ما اخترنا أمهاتنا
ما اخترنا كيف يكونوا في حياتنا
فهل هذا ظلم؟ لا هذا مو ظلم
هذا الرزق اللي جاني، هذا التحدي اللي جاني
ومنه أقدر أصنع شيء يقويني أو شيء يدمرني
ترى الإنسان عنده قدرة الاختيار في الأخير
خلاص لا تروح عليّ الطيارة، ألحق
يلا، الله يعطيك العافية